SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER FOUR WILL
COME TO ORDER. GOOD MORNING
ACTUALLY IT'S GOOD AFTERNOON IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERED
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE ROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME MEMBERS ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTE REMOTELY
TODAY ALL MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE WILL BE HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM. THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASK
THAT EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USE THE
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURED IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO IN MUTE.
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING. R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT CODE IS.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS SIX FIVE FOUR. TWENTY
EIGHT NINETY SEVEN. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES THEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
FOR THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
DISRUPTIVE. MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE-
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED
AND I DON'T EXPECT THAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN TODAY. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT TO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES SO THAT THEY CAN BE
HEARD. BEFORE WE BEGIN WE'RE
GOING TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM MR
HACKER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CABALLERO HERE NIELSEN ROTH
YOUR. THE CONSULTANT NOTES THAT
A QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED
TODAY'S HEARING WILL COVER THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH AS WELL AS HOUSING
ISSUES INCLUDING THE DEPARTMENT
OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AND THE
STATE TREASURER'S OFFICE LOW
INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM. ALTHOUGH TO BE TAKEN
AT THE END OF THE HEARING ONCE
WE HAVE COMPLETED ALL
DISCUSSION ITEMS AND HEARD
PUBLIC COMMENT. SATURDAY
NIELSEN ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE TO
ADD BEFORE WE BEGIN. SENTARA
THE THING NINE NOW WE WILL
BEGIN THE HEARING AS WE ARE
TAKING ACTIONS AT THE END OF
THE HEARING WE WILL SKIP THE
VOTE ON THE ITEMS THAT ARE ON
THE CALENDAR AND WE WILL BEGIN
DISCUSSION WITH ITEM NUMBER
FIVE OFFICE OF PLANNING AND
RESEARCH MINUTES ADMINISTRATIVE
STAFF AUGMENTATION OPR CAN YOU
BEGIN THE PRESENTATION. AND
WELCOME. FOR THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR COMING ERA SHOULD I BE
STARTING OR ARE YOU GOING TO
BUY YOUR STAFF FOR THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE FIRST NO
WILL GO WILL START WITH YOU
THAT'S RIGHT NEXT THANKS SO
MUCH- CHAIR AND SUBCOMMITTEE ON
MY NAME IS KATE GORDON ON THE
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING RESEARCH AND JUST A
LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND I
SPECIALLY FOR THOSE- WATCHING
WHO DON'T KNOW A PR AS WELL AS
YOU DO A REMINDER THAT OPR
SERVES TO PROVIDE LONG RANGE
PLANNING AND POLICY GUIDANCE TO
THE GOVERNOR AND THE CABINET AS
WELL AS THE LEGISLATURE. I WE
ALSO PROVIDE CROSSCUTTING AN
INTERAGENCY COLLABORATION AND
COORDINATION- ACROSS MULTIPLE
ISSUES WITH A WITH A DIRECT
RELATIONSHIP AS WELL WITH
REGIONAL LOCAL GOVERNMENT IN
GENERAL- OUR OFFICE WHICH
INCLUDES UNDERNEATH IT BOTH THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL AND
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS WORKS ON
FOUR MAJOR AREAS OF WORK A ONE
IS LAND USE AND PLANNING WHAT
IS CLIMATE RISK AND RESILIENCE
INCLUDING EMERGENCY RESERVE
RESPONSE ONE IS HIGH ROAD
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND ONE IS
LONG RANGE RESEARCH ON TOPICS
OF IMPORTANCE TO THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE WE RUN A
VERY SMALL AND FOCUSED TEAM BUT
THAT'S HIGHLY EFFICIENT AND
EFFECTIVE- WE HAVE A BUDGET OF
OVER FIVE HUNDRED. MILLION BUT
ONLY NINETY SEVEN STAFF ON THE
BOOKS- AND SO A VERY EFFICIENT
AND LOW ADMIN OVERHEAD
OPERATION THE BCPS FOR THIS
BUDGET FOCUS ON A COUPLE OF
REALLY KEY AREAS TO US ONE IS
ON A SPENDING THE WHAT THE
FIRST ITEM EXPANDING OUR
ADMINISTRATIVE CAPACITY TO KEEP
UP WITH KEY LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
ASSIGNED OPR AS WELL AS THE
GROWTH OF EXISTING PROGRAMS- WE
HAVE BEEN OPERATING-
ADMINISTRATIVE- IN PARTICULAR
GRANTED PROCUREMENT OPERATIONS
AT O. PR AND STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL AND CAL ON CHEERS
SENDING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
PRIMARILY OUT THE DOOR TO
COMMUNITIES TO FOLKS IN NEED.
AGAIN WITH VERY LOW OVERHEAD-
BUT IT'S BECOME WE'VE GOTTEN TO
THE POINT WHERE WE NEED TO
PROVIDE MORE CAPACITY. TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY- ACROSS ALL THREE
OF THE DIFFERENT- PARTS A PR
HAPPY TO ANSWER. LIKE SCOTT
MORGAN MY G. DEPUTY ON THE LINE
AS WELL THE ANSWER QUESTIONS ON
THE SIDE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. HEY
TIM WEBER FINANCE NOTICE-
COMMENTS. ABOUT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. HI BRIAN
WHETHER FORD WITH LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. ARE THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
HAS GROWN OVER RECENT YEARS AND
MANY OF THESE RESPONSIBILITIES
WERE IN PART IMPOSED ON OPR BY
LEGISLATION AND IN PART BY
EXECUTIVE ORDERS THAT MAY
REFLECT PRIORITY SHARED BY MANY
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE. TO
SOME EXTENT OTHER PROPOSALS IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET WILL
CONTINUE TO EXPAND THE SIZE AND
RESPONSIBILITY OF NO PR SO.
SOME INCREASE IN MINISTRY OF
STAFFING IS WARRANTED WE NOTE
THE STAFF COMMENTS IN THE
AGENDA THAT YOU CONSIDER
FUNDING ONLY A PORTION OF THE
REQUEST. WE DO NOT HAVE A
SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATION ON THIS
ITEM BUT WE CAN WORK WITH STAFF
AND ADMINISTRATION- TO NARROW
DOWN WHICH POSITIONS- HAVE- THE
MOST MERIT BASED ON CURRENT
ANTICIPATED RECORDS WHICH MAY
INCLUDE. ALL OF THEM. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THERE ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
STAFF AT FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
CENTER NIELSEN. OF SERVICE ANY
OF YOUR- TRANSITION FUNDING
DERIVED FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS OF ALL GENERAL
FUND FOR THE STATE. WE HAVE
POSITIONS ACTUALLY SIR- FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE DO
HAVE SOME POSITIONS FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT NOT OUR
ADMINISTRATIVE CAPACITY BUT FOR
CERTAIN OF OUR PROGRAMS
PARTICULARLY ON CLIMATE RISK
AND THE WORK THAT WERE
INCREASINGLY DOING WITH FEMA
AND- YES ON COMMUNITY RESPONSE
IN WILDFIRE AFFECTED
COMMUNITIES THAT IS FEMA
FUNDED. US SEVERAL THIS
POSITION TO BE A FUNDED WE RUN
THE MILITARY COUNCIL SEPARATE
THOSE POSITIONS ARE FEDERALLY
FUNDED THE CASCADE PROGRAM HAS
A FEDERALLY FUNDED POSITIONS
AND ACTUALLY A SET OF POSITIONS
AT A PR ARE FUNDED THROUGH
OTHER AGENCIES SO WE HAVE- I
GOT A MIX OF. OUR POLICY
POSITIONS AND- AND IT
IMPLEMENTATION POSITIONS FUNDED
THROUGH THE GENERAL FUND
THROUGH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
THROUGH THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND AND THROUGH
OTHER AGENCIES ARE
ADMINISTRATIVE POSITIONS WERE
ASKING FOR HERE WOULD BE
UNDERLYING ALL OF THOSE
DIFFERENT PIECES AND SUPPORTING
ALL THREE OF THE OVER ONE
PROGRAMS THAT THIS WOULD BE TO
BE GENERAL FUND. BECAUSE WE
WOULD NEED TO BE ON GOING- AND
CONSISTENT- AND PART OF THE
STATE BUDGET SCOTT DID YOU WANT
TO ADD TO THAT. YEAH I WOULD
YEAH I WOULD JUST ADD THAT THE
ALL THE FEDERALLY FUNDED
POSITIONS ARE THROUGH
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROCESS THAT
WE'VE ENTERED INTO AND ARE
LIMITED TERM POSITION SO MOST
OF THOSE ARE OUR EIGHTEEN MONTH
TO TWO TWO YEAR POSITIONS THAT
GO WITH THE EXTENSION OF THOSE
GRANTS- AND SO. WILL GO AWAY
WHEN THOSE GRANTS ARE COMPLETED-
DO YOU HAVE ANY IN. AT SAY THE
LAST FIVE YEARS OF HOW MANY.
POSITIONS YOU HAVE. LOST
BECAUSE OF THE EXTINGUISHING OF
THE FUNDING. FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THE CENTRAL CENTER
THE FUNDING HAVE YOU LOST MANY
POSITIONS. GOT YES WE A AGAIN
THEY THEY RUN WITH THE- WITH
THE GRANTS WE CAN GET YOU THOSE
NUMBERS WE HAVE BEEN PRETTY
SUCCESSFUL IN GETTING
ADDITIONAL GRANTS- FROM
DEPARTMENT DEFENSE AND FEMALE
THAT THAT HAVE THEY HAVE
EXTENDED SOME OF THOSE
POSITIONS OR HAVE YOU KNOW WE
BROUGHT ON OTHER PEOPLE YOU
KNOW TO FILL THOSE GRANT NEEDS
SO- THE NUMBERS MIGHT YOU KNOW
FLUCTUATE ONE OR TWO HERE AND
THERE YOU KNOW IT'S NOT WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT YOU KNOW TENS
OF POSITIONS WERE TALKING ABOUT
THAT FOUR FIVE SIX POSITIONS
TOTAL- BASED ON THAT FOUR FIVE
GRANTS THAT WOULD THAT WE
MANAGE. A DURING A GIVEN
PERIOD- BUT WE CAN GET BACK TO
YOU ON ON THOSE NUMBERS IF
YOU'D LIKE TO DEFINITELY A-
CURIOSITY. EACH YEAR HAVE HAD
SOME PRETTY SIGNIFICANT. PEOPLE
I GROWTH IN THE LAST FEW YEARS.
HAS IT ALL BEEN DRIVEN BY
EXECUTIVE ORDERS AND STATUTES
OR HAVE THERE BEEN OTHER
FACTORS THE NEW INITIATIVES BY
THE GOVERNOR FOR EXAMPLE. IN
GENERAL IT'S BEEN LEGISLATIVE
AS YOU HEARD FOR THE L. L.
LEGISLATIVE AND EXECUTIVE ORDER
SO- I NUMBER OF PIECES OF THE
GROWTH YOU'LL SEE A BIG PIECE
OF GROWTH FROM OUR AYE
INTEGRATION OF THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNCIL WHICH WAS NOT
ORIGINALLY HOUSED AT OPR. NOW
IT IS- I HE SAID THAT THAT
COUNCIL HAS GROWN- YES IT IT
RUNS A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
MONEY AND LOUISE BATS WORK
EXACTLY DIRECTORS HERE A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF GRANT
MONEY RUN FOR THAT PROGRAM
THAT'S MOSTLY FUNDED THROUGH
THE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUND- AND SAID THAT PROGRAM HAS
ABSOLUTELY GROWN YOU'VE ALSO
SEEN- GROWTH. THROUGH THE
CREATION OF THE INTEGRATED
CLIMATE ADAPTATION RESILIENCE
PROGRAMMER I CARP WHICH IS A
LEGISLATIVELY. MANDATED PROGRAM
GROW THROUGH THE AYE THE
CLIMATE- THAT- THE CCR PROGRAM
OR THE CLIMATE CHANGE RESEARCH
PROGRAM ALSO IF YOU'RE
STATUTES- THE- DRIVE COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE PROGRAM THROUGH
STATUTES SO A NUMBER OF
STATUTES HAVE REGIONAL CLIMATE
COLLABORATIVE START THE STATUTE
CAN SEVENTY TWO. A NUMBER OF
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN CREATED YOUR
STATUTE OUGHT TO OF OUR BIG
RESEARCH PROGRAMS THE PRECISION
MEDICINE PROGRAM AND THE ONLINE
LEARNING PROGRAM BOTH CREATED
YOUR STATUTES- AND- I NUMBER
BROTHER SO ABSOLUTELY THERE
HAVE BEEN STATUTORY GROWTH I
WOULD SAY THAT'S MOST OF OUR
GROUP A LITTLE BIT OF GROWTH.
THROUGH EXECUTIVE ORDER SOME OF
THE OTHER ITEMS WILL BE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY ARE EXECUTIVE
ORDER- DIRECTED BUT WHEN WE
HAVE EXECUTIVE ORDER DIRECTION
WE TRY OUR BEST TO DO THAT WITH
EXISTING STAFF EXISTING
EXPERTISE AND BY LEVERAGING
OTHER AGENCIES WHICH IS A BIG.
PART OF HOW WE DO OUR JOBS. K.
FISHING QUESTION- SURE OF- AND-
OF THE TWO. THE ONE HERE FOR
YOU. DIRECTOR IS. THE.
MEASURABLES DO YOU HAVE WAGED
OF TRACKING THE SUCCESSES OF
THE SHIP IF YOU WILL FEDERAL
INVESTMENTS IN VARIOUS PROGRAMS
DO YOU HAVE THE VEGETABLES THAT
YOU CAN BE REPORTED TO US. WE
DO ALL TALK AT THE OPR LEVEL
FOR MEN AND THEN I'LL HAVE LOSE
BETS WORTH I'M FROM S. G. SE
BECAUSE THAT'S A BIG BIG PIECE
OF OUR PROGRAM INTO SP CE AND
THEN AND THEN YOU HAVE AS YOUR
FROM CHALFONT TEARS. MOST OF
OUR GRANT MONEY GOES OUT
THROUGH THOSE TWO PROGRAMS FROM
THE OPR PERSPECTIVE. ARE- OUR
CENTRAL. FUNCTION IS REALLY.
THESE LONG RANGE INITIATIVES
PROVIDING GUIDANCE PROVIDING
COLLABORATION AND SUPPORT
ACROSS AGENCIES. SO A FAIR
AMOUNT OF THAT IS FRANKLY
MEASURED IN TERMS OF GUIDANCE
WE ARE. PRODUCED THE GENERAL
PLAN IMPLEMENTATION GUIDELINES
WOULD PRODUCE THE SEQUEL
GUIDELINES. THOSE ARE ALL
AVAILABLE AND PRESENT ON OUR
WEBSITE WE RUN THIS DEEPER
CLEARING HOUSE WHICH- IS A DAY
BY DAY OPERATION OF COLLECTING
ALL OF THE SECRET DOCUMENTS IN
THE STATE. MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE MAINTAINING THAT CLEARING
HOUSE WE MAINTAIN THE CLEARING
HOUSE OF. FEDERAL GRANTS COMING
TO THE STATE AND WE DO A
NEWSLETTER. LETTING THE EST
THE STATE KNOW ABOUT HOW TO
READ OPPORTUNITIES SO A LOT OF
WHAT WE DO WITH THE- PR LEVEL
IS FRANKLY. GUIDANCE ASSISTANCE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND THEN-
WORK ACROSS AGENCIES TO MAKE
SURE FRANKLY THAT. AGENCIES ARE
ALIGNED AROUND MAJOR
INITIATIVES OF THE OVERALL
GOVERNMENT INCLUDING.
RIDICULOUSLY CLIMATE CHANGE AND
OUR GOAL OF HAVING A MORE
SUSTAINABLE. ECONOMIC GROWTH
AND PLANNING STRATEGY GOING
FORWARD. OF THE TWO PROGRAMS
WHERE MOST OF THE MONEY IS
GOING OUT THE DOOR OUR-
DISTRICT YOU'RE GREAT COUNCIL
CALENDAR SO LET ME JUST ASK
LOSE BEDS WITH YOU TALK FOR
JUST A MINUTE. ABOUT THEIR
METRICS THANK YOU. HI YES
LOUISE. EXACT DIRECTOR OF THE
STRATEGIC COUNCIL WE COLLECT
INFORMATION BOTH IN ACCORDANCE
WITH ALL OF THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE INVESTMENTS PROTOCOLS
AND FROM CALIFORNIA RESOURCES
BOARD. BUT PER AT SHE C.
STATUTE WE ALSO PREPARE AN
ANNUAL REPORT THA WE SUBMIT TO
THE LEGISLATURE THAT WE- ARE
JUST A MINUTE ACTUALLY LAST
AUGUST OUR MOST RECENT ANNUAL
REPORT THAT CHRONICLES. ALL OF
THE GRANTS THAT WE HAVE MADE-
THE LOCATIONS BUT THEN ALSO
METRICS SUCH AS- THE NUMBER OF
HOUSING UNITS THAT HAVE
PRODUCED ACRES OF LAND
CONSERVED. ALL ASSOCIATED WITH
EACH OF THE PROGRAMS THAT WE
ADMINISTER AND WE'D BE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE YOU THAT IN NO REPORT
ASWELL. OKAY THANK YOU AT LAKE
GENESIS TO BE THE LAST QUESTION
HERE NOT SURE. ANNALISTIC BASED
ON THOSE METRICS- HOW DO YOU
ASSESS TE SUCCESSES. IN THESE
PROGRAMS BY THE. GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH.
THE DALLAS. YES THIS IS BRIAN
WITH THE FORWARD- SO THERE ARE
A OF WIDE RATE FRIDAY
PROGRAMMATIC AREAS THAT OPR
COVERS AND I DON'T HAVE MY
COLLEAGUES WITH THOSE
PARTICULAR AREAS OF EXPERTISE-
WITH ME TODAY I WILL NOTE. THAT
MANY OF THESE PROGRAMS ARE
RELATIVELY NEW AND SO- IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING WE'RE STILL- YOU
KNOW THE SERVING HOW THESE
PROGRAMS ARE ARE PLAYING OUT
AND WHAT OUTCOMES THEY ARE AS-THE- BOOK CARE NOTED THEY ARE
COLLECTING. THIS METRICS ON
THEM SO- WHAT WE CONTINUE TO
FOLLOW THEM BUT WE CAN- FOLLOW
CHRIS THAT WITH YOUR STAFF IF
YOU HAVE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS I'D
LIKE US TO LOOK INTO. IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE WE WOULD
APPRECIATE IT I HAVE HIGH
RESPECTFOR YOUR AGENCY GOING
BACK TO THE ALLEN POST DAIS
AND- MATT TAYLOR WAS A- I WANT
TO THE SAME HIGH SCHOOL AS I
DID AND- THE BEST PANIC WE-
HAVE A HIGH REGARD FOR HIM AS
WELL SO. WE WOULD WELCOME THAT
INFORMATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS THIS IS AN ITEM THAT
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP OPEN BUT I
WOULD- THAT SUGGESTS THAT THERE
BE SOME DISCUSSION BETWEEN THE
L. A. O. N. AS PART IN A
FINANCE ABOUT. THE PARTICULARS
OF THESE. OF THIS REQUEST AND
IT TO REALLY IDENTIFY THE
POSITIONS THAT- THEY SHOULD BE
FUNDED AT THIS PARTICULAR POINT
IN TIME. SO WE'LL MOVE ON THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY WILL
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER SIX
WITH THE WHICH IS THE JUST
TRANSITION ROADMAP. THANK YOU
SO MUCH CHAIRS SO. UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S RECENT EXECUTIVE
ORDER SEVENTY NINE TWENTY WHICH
WAS THE EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT
CALLED FOR THE STATE TO- I'D
BOUGHT I HAVE A CELL ONLY ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE ONE OF THE PIECES
OF THAT EXECUTIVE WORK. POINTED
TO THE OFFICE OF PLANNING
RESEARCH WORKING WITH THE LABOR
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY. ON DEVELOPING A JUST
TRANSITION ROADMAP THIS IS A
CRITICAL PIECE OF OUR OVERALL
STATE GOAL. OF GETTING TO A
SUSTAINABLE AND RESILIENT AND
INCLUSIVE CALIFORNIA A CARBON
NEUTRAL CALIFORNIA BY TWENTY
FORTY FIVE. I'M DOING THAT
ACROSS MANY SECTORS AND REGIONS
OF THE STATE WILL REQUIRE A
TRANSITION OF SOME COMMUNITIES
FROM VERY RESOURCE INTENSIVE
INDUSTRIES. A WORKER TRANSITION
THERE ARE TAX BASES THAT ARE
DEPENDENT ON SOME OF THESE
INDUSTRIES- TRANSPORTATION IS
ONE OF THEM- IT'S ONE OF OUR
LARGEST AREAS OF TRANSFORMATION
IN THE STATE. BOTH FROM A
VEHICLE IF YOU'LL PERSPECTIVE
BUT ALSO IN TERMS OF HOW OUR
CITY IS A BIG PART OF WHAT
APPEARED AS HOW ARE CITIES ARE
DESIGNED AND BUILT. THE
QUESTION OF JUST TRANSITION IS
BY DEFINITION AN INTER AGENCY
ISSUE IT GOES TO. NOT ONLY
THINKING ABOUT ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT INITIATIVES ACROSS
AGAIN REGIONS AND SECTORS AND
WHAT KINDS OF THE IMPACT OF
CLIMATE POLICIES. MAY HAVE ON
THOSE COMMUNITIES- IT ALSO GOES
TO THE DIRECT IMPACT CLIMATE
CHANGE IS HAVING TODAY ON SOME
OF OUR COMMUNITIES FOR INSTANCE
YOU'RE A SUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT ACT.
RESPONSE TO OUR DROUGHT
CONDITIONS AND WHAT THAT MAY
LOOK LIKE ON THE GROUND
ECONOMICALLY AND HOW TO PLAN
FOR THOSE TRANSITIONS. ALL THE
PLANNING AND RESEARCH IS BY
DEFINITION AN INTER AGENCY
BODY- WORKING DIRECTLY UNDER
THE GOVERNOR'S PURVIEW WORKING
ACROSS ALL OF THE OTHER
AGENCIES AND WHAT WE CALL THE
CLIMATE CABINET TO ALL THE
OTHER AGENCIES THAT WORK ON.
THESE POLICIES WE ARE IN A VERY
GOOD POSITION. TO BE
COORDINATING THAT WORK FIGHTING
THOSE AREAS OF TRANSITION
IDENTIFYING KEY RESOURCES
ACROSS OTHER AGENCIES. TO HELP
REGIONS AND SECTORS DEAL WITH
THE TRANSITION WORKING WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES GO BAD LABOR. AND
OTHER AGENTS TO DO THAT- THIS
THIS B. C. ASK US- IS. FOR
FUNDING PRESS FOR TO POSITIONS
ONE IS A POSITION THAT WE
CURRENTLY ARE BORROWING FROM
LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. BUT WE HAVE TO
RENEW IT ON AN ANNUAL BASIS AND
IT COMES OUT OF THEIR RAPID
RESPONSE FUNDING WHICH WE
ANTICIPATE WILL BE NEEDED FOR.
IMMEDIATE COVERED RESPONSE AND
A NUMBER OF INDUSTRIES. WE'RE
ASKING FOR A CONTINUOUS FUNDING
FOR THAT POSITION AS WELL AS
ONE ADDITIONAL POSITION. TO RUN
WHAT'S ESSENTIALLY GOING TO BE
A COORDINATED STATEWIDE
STRATEGY ON TRANSITION. I
SHOULD JUST NOTE THAT MANY
OTHER STATES THAT ARE WORKING I
JUST TRANSITION ISSUES HAVE
ENTIRE AGENCIES DEVOTED. TO
THIS ISSUE WE ARE- AS WE DO IN
GENERAL WORKING TO DO THIS WITH
A VERY EFFICIENT- VERY LEAN
THAT STOP APPROACH AND IT WITH
COORDINATION A LEVERAGING OF
EXISTING RESOURCES- I WILL SHOP
THERE AND GO BACK TO YOUR-
MANAGER. THANK YOU HAVE A
QUESTION THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
LET'S HEAR FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE IN THE L. A- AND
THEN WE'LL GET YOUR QUESTION
SIR- IF WE COULD HEAR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THEY
MIGHT WORD OF OUR TO FINANCE
NOTICE- COMMENT. THANK YOU HOW
ABOUT THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. YES THIS DIRECTOR
GORDON NOTED THIS IS AN INTER
AGENCY ISSUE IN THE TRANSITION
LIKELY IS TO SPEND MANY YEARS-
WE SO WE DON'T HAVE SPECIFIC
COMMENTS ON THAT ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE ISSUE BUT IT MAY BE-
YOU KNOW TO WORTH CONSIDERING.
THAT THE THAT THE JOINT- THAT
THE JUST TRANSITION ROADMAP IS
NOT GOING TO BE FULLY DEVELOPED
UNTIL JULY SO IT IS CHALLENGING
TO EVALUATE WHETHER OPR IS THE
BEST LONG TERM HOME FOR THE
FUNCTION AND WHAT I'M GOING
STAFF THING. IS NEEDED SO YOU
MAY WANT TO CONSIDER INSTEAD
PROVIDING A ONE TIME FUNDING
THIS YEAR AND REVISIT IT LATER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIRTY
NIELSEN. PROVIDE GENERALIST
WILL THESE POSITIONS. BE
INSTRUCTIVE TO THE LEGISLATURE
AS WE DEAL WITH THE VERY
TROUBLED EDT AGENCY THAT AGENCY
IS IN DESPERATE NEED OF CHANGE.
WILL ANY OF THESE- CONTACTS
THERE BE OF HELP TO GUIDE US IN
FUTURE HEARINGS AS TO HOW WE
DEAL WITH EDT. SO I AM NOT-
FAMILIAR WITH HOW THESE
POSITIONS- WHICH INTERACT WITH
EDT THAT MIGHT BE- QUESTION WE
COULD- CORRECT TO THE
ADMINISTRATION OKAY SURE. AND
THEN I THOUGHT I'D LIKE IN THE
FUTURE HEARING MADAM CHAIR TO
ASK SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT THE PLANT. SO WE
DON'T NEED TO DEAL WITH THAT
NOW BUT- ALREADY- I CAN GIVE A
LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND. THE
REASON EDT I. COMES UP AT ALL
IN THIS CONVERSATION IS SIMPLY
THAT EDT DOES THE
ADMINISTRATION OF MANY
CONTRACTS THROUGH THE LABOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY.
THE CONTRACT HERE- THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE FOR THE POSITION
FOR THE ROAD MAP COMES FROM
LABOR WORKFORCE DOMINATED SHE
HAPPENS TO BE ON A CONTRACT YOU
ET DE BUT WE ARE NOT DIRECTLY
INTERFACING WITH THE DATE. ON
THIS WORK SO I DON'T THINK THAT
THE TWO ISSUES ARE DIRECTLY
RELATED. I WILL SAY- IN
RESPONSE TO THE L. A. O.
COMMENTED THAT. ALTHOUGH THE
JUST TRANSITION ROAD MAP IS DUE
IN JULY AT THE EXECUTIVE ORDER
SPECIFICALLY SAYS THAT IT WILL
THEN NEED TO BE IMPLEMENTED.
AND A JUST TRANSITION AS AS WE
ALL KNOW I THINK IS A LONG GAME
IT'S GOING TO TAKE YEARS IT IS
GOING TO BE DIFFERENT IN
DIFFERENT REGIONS AND SECTORS-
WE BELIEVE OPR IS IN A VERY
IMPORTANT POSITION TO HELP.
ALIGN REGIONAL LOCAL AND AGENCY
RESOURCES TOWARD. MAKING SURE
THAT THAT IS A TRANSITION THAT
IS FAIR CREATES GOOD HIGH
QUALITY JOBS AND- IT IS- IS
INCLUSIVE SO WE SEE THIS AS A-
ONGOING- SET OF IT- OF
ACTIVITIES NOT I'M NOT AN ASSET
ACTIVITIES ENDING IN JULY.
THANK YOU. THE FOR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I'M SORRY THIS IS A-
I. THAT A HOLD OPEN ITEM AND I
GUESS MY COMMENT TO THIS IS THE
FOLLOWING IS THAT- THE CONCERN
I HAVE IS THAT THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE ARE GOING TO BE
FELT DIFFERENTLY THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AND THE BAND IN THE
COASTAL REGIONS WILL SUFFER IN
A WAY THAT'S VERY DIFFERENT
THAN THE INLAND REGIONS. AND
TO- HAVE THIS. DISCUSSION
CONVERSATION AND PLANNING.
HAPPEN WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE
INPUT OR DIRECTION OR
PARTICIPATION HAS ME GREATLY
CONCERNED- AND AWAY
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE IN MANY OF
OUR COUNTIES. THERE'S A FEELING
THAT THE STATE GIVES IT
DISCRETION TO DEPARTMENTS AND
THEY'RE ON AUTOMATIC PILOT
PILOT AND THEY MAKE DECISIONS
WITHOUT CONSULTING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND SOME OF THOSE
DECISIONS HAVE A TREMENDOUS
IMPACT EITHER ON RATE PAYERS
AND THAT IN THE DISTRICTS OR ON
THE- BEYOND THE COST TO
BUSINESSES IN THE DISTRICT SO
I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED WITH.
WITH AN AUTOMATIC PILOT-
PROGRAM OR OR HAVING THE
ADMINISTRATION DESIGN A PROGRAM
AND SAY THIS IS WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO BECAUSE I DO AGREE
WITH YOU I THINK THIS IS A LONG
TERM- AT PLANNING PROCESS AND I
DO BELIEVE- P. R. IS IN THE
BEST POSITION. TO BE ABLE TO
GUIDE SOME OF THIS WORK BUT I
THINK- AT LEAST THAT AT FIRST
BLUSH AND I'D LIKE TO HAVE A
CHANCE TO HAVE MORE
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU. ON IT
APPEARS TO ME THAT THIS IS THAT
THIS IS. THAT WE WOULD BE
PUTTING. SOMETHING THAT WILL
DECIDE DECIDE THE FUTURE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IN THE
HANDS OF THE ADMINISTRATION
WITHOUT ANY LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT TRIBE I JUST THAT'S
MY GUT REACTION TO THIS IS A
HOLDOVER ITEM THERE'S MORE
DISCUSSION TO BE HAD. BUT BUT I
AM CONCERNED ABOUT ABOUT THAT
SO- WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THIS
OPEN WILL HAVE SOME MORE
CONVERSATIONS AND- WELL I'M
ASSUMING WILL. WILL WILL HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO HASH THROUGH
THAT. SO THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO. ISSUE
NUMBER SEVEN. WHICH IS THE
REGIONAL CLIMATE COLLABORATIVE
PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION. I WILL
HAVE MY COLLEAGUE LOUISE THAT'S
WORK FROM STC TAKE THIS ITEM.
THREE THANK YOU- KERR CABALLERO
AND MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
AGAIN I'M LOUISE THAT'S WORTH
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL- STC IS REQUESTING FIVE
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO FUNDS AND I'M GOING.
TO MAINTAIN STAFFING FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SENATE BILL
TEN SEVENTY TWO. WHICH DIRECTS
STC TO UNDERTAKE US SERIES OF
ACTIVITIES TO SUPPORT UNDER
RESOURCE COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE TO HELP THEM ACCESS
FUNDING- THIS INCLUDES THE
DEVELOPMENT OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE GUIDELINES FOR STATE
AGENCIES. AS WELL AS
ESTABLISHING AND ADMINISTERING
THE REGIONAL CLIMATE
COLLABORATIVE'S PROGRAM- IN
MINISTRY AT LEAST TWO ROUNDS OF
FUNDING OVER TEN YEARS. I S.
YOU SEE RECEIVED FUNDING IN THE
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT FOR
TWO YEARS OF STAFFING FOR THE
PROGRAM. AND DURING THAT TIME
WE HAVE. COMPLETED AND ADOPTED
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
GUIDELINES FOR STATE AGENCIES.
INCLUDING THE DEVELOPMENT OF AN
APPENDIX TO SUPPORT TA FOR
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS. AND TRIBAL
SERVING ORGANIZATIONS. WE
DEVELOP THESE. ASK THROUGH AN
INTER AGENCY PROCESS AS WELL AS
A ROBUST SERIES OF PUBLIC
COMMENTS- ONE THING THE GROUP
IDENTIFIED- IN DOING THIS WORK
WHAT IS THE NEED FOR CONTINUED
ENGAGEMENT AND SUPPORT AS THE
STATE BUILDS OUT ITS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. ARE WE ALSO
CONTINUE TO ADMINISTER THE CAT
A TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE INVESTMENTS
PROGRAM. BOTH SUPPORTING OUR
OWN PROGRAMS AND IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH OTHER AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS- WE'VE CONDUCTED
AND EARLY EVALUATION ACTUALLY
HAVE ANOTHER ON GOING OF THESE
TA EFFORTS BUT WHAT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT AS WE SHOWN THAT.
APPLICANTS THAT RECEIVE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. FAR OUT
COMPETE THOSE THAT DO NOT AND
THAT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. BY
LEVELING THE PLAYING FIELD
ACROSS THE STATE IN ACCESSING
STATE RESOURCES AND FUNDS.
FINALLY THIS YEAR- WE LAUNCHED
A LEADERSHIP TRAINING
INITIATIVES- CALL PARTNERS
ADVANCING CLIMATE EQUITY USING
OUR TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT
APPROPRIATION FOR TA. AND THEN
WE AUGMENTEDTHAT WITH A GRANT
WE SECURED FROM U. S. EPA. I
THIS PROGRAMS GOING TO SUPPORT
A COHORT OF TWENTY TWO
COMMUNITY LEADERS TO BUILD
PARTNERSHIPS AND GRANT READY
MISS THROUGH LEADERSHIP
TRAINING. BUILDING FAMILIARITY
WITH STATE FUNDING AND PROGRAMS
AND OTHER OPPORTUNITIES AND THE
DEVELOPMENT OF COMMUNITY NEEDS
ASSESSMENTS WE SEE THIS WORK IS
PROVIDING FOUNDATIONAL WORK FOR
FUTURE REGIONAL CLIMATE
COLLABORATIVE'S. I AS NOTED IN
THE STAFF ANALYSIS WE DO NOT
CURRENTLY HAVE FUNDING FOR THE
GRANT FUNDING IN THE PROGRAM. I
BELIEVE THINK CONTINUED
STAFFING IS A CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO MEET THE GOALS OF
THE LEGISLATION AND TO CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT AND PARTNER WITH
UNDER RESOURCE COMMUNITIES- AND
SPECIFICALLY AGAIN THIS ONE
COULD IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
GUIDELINES- WE'RE ALSO WORKING
TO DEVELOP THE FRAMEWORK FOR
THE REGIONAL CLIMATE CLEVERNESS
PROGRAMS THAT WE WILL BE. READY
WHEN FUNDING BECOMES AVAILABLE
TO RAPIDLY DEPLOY THAT FINDING
AND ADMINISTER GRANTS TO
COMMUNITIES- AND THEN WE WILL
CONTINUE TO IMPLEMENT- THE
PARTNERS ADVANCINGJUSTICE AND
EQUITY WORK AND A NUMBER OF
OTHER TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
INITIATIVES WE HAVE UNDERWAY.
THAT. ARE BUILDING COMMUNITY
CAPACITY. TIMES CLOSE- IN NO
THAT THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
NEEDS AND CAPACITY BUILDING
NEEDS OF OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE
ONLY BEEN HEIGHTENED DURING THE
COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC. ARE
WHERE WE ARE SEEING SOME OF THE
LARGEST IMPACTS IN OUR MOST
UNDER RESOURCE COMMUNITIES. THE
PROVISION OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND CAPACITY
BUILDING HAS BEEN SHOWN TO BE
VERY COST EFFICIENT I IN A WAY
TO SUPPORT COMMUNITIES WE SEEM
COMMUNITIES DOWN THE ACCESS NOT
JUST STATE FUNDING BUT OTHER
FUNDING PROGRAMS AS WELL-
THROUGH SOME OF OUR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PARTNERSHIPS. ASU AT
A MINIMUM THE CONTINUATION OF
THIS FUNDING WILL ENABLE S. YOU
SEE TO CONTINUE TO CARRY THIS
WORK FORWARD- AND WE THINK IT'S
A REALLY IMPORTANT ELEMENT OF
THE STATE'S WORK TO SUPPORT
COMMUNITIES. SO WITH THAT I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND VERY MUCH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I
REMEMBER DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WONDER ON THE GRANT FUNDING
THAT WE INITIALLY INCLUDING
GRANT FUNDING LAST YEAR HOWEVER
WAS ALSO NOT INCLUDED IN THE
FINAL BUDGET. WILL CONTINUE
LOOKING AT THE POSSIBILITY OF
PREFERENCE FUTURE BUT AS WE
SAID THERE'S A LOT OF WORK THAT
I JUST R. C. PROGRAM DOES
INCLUDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
THAT. CREATE DIFFERENT
PARTNERSHIPS. OHIO WE ARE NOT
RAISING CONCERNS WITH THIS ITEM
AT THIS TIME VERY GOOD. MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. SENATOR
NELSON COULD DO AB. I GUESS
FINANCIER GIVE THE NAMES OF A
FEW COMMUNITIES TO TWO THREE
FIVE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE BEING
SERVED. AND SOME OF THE
CONNECTIVITY AS THESE
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN DIRECTED
TO WORK WITH CERTAIN AGENCIES I
GUESS OF THE STATE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DRUG KIND INVASION
THE NETWORK THE FLOW CHART.
SHOW IT THE CLERK IN THE
QUESTION WOULD BE COMMUNITIES
SERVED AND WHAT RESOURCES HAVE
THEY BEEN LINKED WITH THROUGH
THIS. EXPENDITURES THESE
EXPENDITURES. I DO FOR YOU AS
YOU SEE ON THE CITRIX I HAD
THAT FROM ME I COULD ALSO GET
BACK TO YOU YOUR STAFF A LATER
DATE OKAY THAT THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE YOU KNOW WE
HAVE TO. LOOK AT IT IN REAL
TIME AND REAL CIRCUMSTANCE AND
IN REAL RESULTS SO FREE TO GET
BACK ON THAT POINT THANK YOU
SENATOR SENATOR NELSON I'M THIS
IS LOUISE I'LL JUST STEP IN FOR
A MOMENT TO SAY WERE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE A COMPREHENSIVE LIST OF
ALL THE COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN SERVED- WE HAVE REACHED-
YOU KNOW MANY MANY COMMUNITY
SIR PROGRAMMATIC TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE SO THROUGH THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES PROGRAM
WE WORK WITH. MANY OF OUR
APPLICANTS EACH YEAR WE'VE ALSO
HAD AN INITIATIVE WITH THE
INSTITUTE FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT-
SERVING A NUMBER OF SPECIFIC
COMMUNITIES OR SOMETHING CALLED
THE BOOST INITIATIVE- AND SO I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE THAT
COMPREHENSIVE LIST I HINK
YOU'LL SEE IT IS A BROAD
SPECTRUM ON GEOGRAPHY. ON
PROGRAMMATIC NEXUS AND ON ON
WHAT THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO
ACCESS BOTH IN TERMS OF OUR OWN
STATE FUNDING BUT OTHER FUNDING
PROGRAMS AS WELL. HAVE YOU
DEALT WITH DELVED INTO OR
WORKED. WITH THE TINY HOMES.
THAT THE IRAQIS ARE THE HMO. TO
IN THE THAT I. THE TIMING TRIPS
PROJECT I THINK OF THE- ANY
WITH THE TIME HOME. I WOULD
HAVE TO LOOK MORE SPECIFICALLY
IN SOME OF OUR- PLACE BASED
INITIATIVES DIDN'T UNDERSTAND-
WHAT TYPE OF THE NEXUS WE'VE
HAD THERE WE CERTAINLY WORKED
ON A NUMBER OF HOUSING ISSUES-
BOTH AGAIN THROUGH AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES BUT THEN ALSO WITH.
OTHER PLACES THAT ARE LOOKING
TO DEVELOP COMMUNITY LAND
TRUSTS- ACCESSORY DWELLING
UNITS AND OTHER SOLUTIONS THAT
REALLY FIT FOR THEIR COMMUNITY
CONTEXT. THANK MEASURE THANK
YOU VERY GOOD- IN DIRECTOR
MAYBE YOU CAN EXPLAIN TO ME WHY
THERE'S NO MONEY FOR ANOTHER NO
REQUEST FOR GRANT FUNDING AND
ONLY FIRST FOR STAFF RIGHT IF
IT IT'S ODD TO ME THAT THIS IS
A GRANT PROGRAM AND I TOTALLY
SUPPORT THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE- FOR UNDER RESEARCH
COMMUNITY TO NO QUESTION ABOUT
IT BUT AT SOME POINT. YOU KNOW
AFTER TWO YEARS OF. FUNDING FOR
STAFF. WE STILL HAVE A REUEST
FOR GRANT MONEY AND I'M
WONDERING WHAT IS IT THAT STAFF
IS DOING AND- I THIS PROGRAM
WAS. ORGANIZED SO THAT IT WOULD
BE M. T. A. WITH WITH GRANT'S
GOING OUT TO TELL ME TELL ME
WHY THERE WAS NO REQUEST FOR
GRANTED THIS TIME. I'M YES SO
WE HAVE REQUESTED GRANT FUNDING
IN THE PAST- AND THAT HIS- AND
NOT COME THROUGH I THINK WE
ARE. READY AND ABLE TO
ADMINISTER GRANT FUNDING SHOULD
IT BECOME AVAILABLE I THINK THE
DECISION THIS YEAR WAS ALSO
AROUND- CURRENT CONSTRAINTS ON
THE STATE BUDGET BUT- OUR TEAM
IS ABSOLUTELY READY AND ABLE TO
ADMINISTER THOSE FUNDS AND WE
STARTED TENANTS TO SKETCH OUT
WHAT A PROGRAM LIKE THAT. COULD
LOOK LIKE AND SO OUR GOAL IS
REALLY TO BE READY TO
ADMINISTER FUNDING SHOULD BE
AVAILABLE. AND WE FEEL THAT
WERE IN THAT POSITION. I WOULD
JUST ALSO ADD- THANK YOU LOUISE
TO THAT THAT- THAT THIS KIND OF
TECHNICAL SYSTEMS AND CAPACITY
BUILDING. IS ALSO INCREDIBLY
CRITICAL IN SUPPORTING.
POTENTIAL BOND FUNDING FOR
INSTANCE IF THAT WERE TO
COMMENT THROUGH I KNOW THEY'RE
SEVERAL BILLS BEING CONSIDERED.
ARE ROUND I CLIMATE RESILIENCE
ANOTHER BOND MONIES AND THAT
THIS KIND OF PROGRAM CAN'T BE
FUNDED THROUGH BONDS BUT IS
DIRECTLY SUPPORTED DO THOSE
TYPES OF PROGRAMS AND SO THAT'S
REALLY HOW. LOUISE AND HER TEAM
HAVE DESIGNED THE PROGRAM
SHOULD BE. TO BE ADDITIVE AND
SUPPORTIVE OF OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT ARE HAPPENING ACROSS THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL
AGENCIES WHICH INCLUDES SEVEN
DIFFERENT AGENCIES OF THE STATE
GOVERNMENT. VERY GOOD THIS IS A
HOLD OPEN ITEMS SO WE WILL HOLD
IT OPEN AND- MOVE ONTO THE
NEXT. THE NEXT ISSUE WHICH IS
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT WHICH IS
WILDFIRE AND FOREST RESILIENCE
STRATEGY ITS THE- CARE
COMPONENT. BACK TO ME- THANK
YOU IT CHAIR CAMBIADO I WILL
JUST SAY THAT I'M I THINK
YOU'VE YOU'VE PROBABLY HAD A
CHANCE TO DISCUSS AND LOOK AT
THE- LARGER WILDFIRE BUDGET
PROPOSAL THAT CAME OUT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT IS AN
EARLY ACTION PROPOSAL TO A
GREAT EXTENT. THERE IS A PIECE
OF THAT PROPOSAL THAT FOCUSES
ON ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
I'LL JUST TALK ABOUT THAT FOR A
MINUTE BECAUSE OF A THAT IS
THAT A PIECE THAT IS SHARED
BETWEEN GO BIZ AND OPR. WE ALL
KNOW THAT WILDFIRE RESPONSE IN
FOREST MANAGEMENT ARE CRITICAL
CRITICAL NEEDS OF OUR STATE
NEEDS URGENT TOP OF MY NEEDS.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT- IS TALK
ABOUT A LITTLE BIT LESS IS THAT
THROUGHALL THE FOREST
MANAGEMENT ACTIVITIES THAT
WE'RE DOING AT THE STATE AND
HAVE BEEN DOING. I THROUGH S.
B. NOT A ONE AND OTHER OTHER
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES. IS
BRINGING A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF BIOMASS FOREST BIOMASS OUT
OF THE FOREST AS PART OF
REPORTS MANAGEMENT A WILDFIRE
REDUCTION STRATEGY. I THAT
BIOMASS IS IN SOME CASES OF
BEING LEFT ON THE SIDE OF THE
ROAD OR IN FACT BEING PILED
BURNED IN SOME CASES THAT IS
ALSO TRUE OF SOME OF THE WOODY
BIOMASS WE HAVE COMING OUT OF-
ORCHARDS AND OTHER AGRICULTURAL
LANDS. AT THE SAME TIME THESE
ARE ALSO COMMUNITIES THAT
REALLY DESPERATELY NEED
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT APPROACHES
TO SUPPORT OUGHT TO SUPPORT
THEM IN SOME WAYS- I WOULD SAY
CHAIR THAT THAT THESE ARE.
THESE ARE REGIONS THAT NEED A
JUST TRANSITION STRATEGY THAT
THAT HAVE ARE LOOKING FOR A
REGIONALLY DRIVEN STRATEGY ON
HOW TO USE EXISTING RESOURCE
AND REALLY MOVE INTO A MORE
SUSTAINABLE SET OF INDUSTRIES.
WE REALLY SEE- THE BUDGET
REQUEST IN A WILDFIRE PROPOSAL
WHICH IS A REQUEST FOR THREE
MILLION DOLLARS- TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION WOULD BE FOR A SET OF
FIVE PILOT PROJECTS. AND FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND FOR IDEAL
LEVERAGE ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR
AN X. PRIZE THESE WOULD REALLY
BE FOCUSED ON. HELPING TO
SUPPORT SOME OF THE MOST
INNOVATIVE IDEAS COMING OUT OF
THESE REGIONS AND
COLLABORATIONS IN THESE REGIONS
TO IDENTIFY TWO AND OVERCOME
MARKET BARRIERS TO USING THAT
BIOMASS AND TURNING IT INTO A
VIABLE INDUSTRY. WHETHER THAT'S
AS- I SUSTAINABLE- HI ABA. FUEL
INDUSTRY A CROSS ONE TO TEN
INDUSTRY. BUILDING TEMPER
DRIVER THINGS THE TINY HOMES
THAT. THAT CENTER NIELSEN
TALKED ABOUT. THESE AREAS HAVE
COALITIONS OF FOLKS WHO WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH FOR YEARS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THEM THROUGH THE
WOOD UTILIZATION GROUP OF THE
FOREST. MANAGEMENT TASK FORCE
THEY HAVE GREAT IDEAS THEY WANT
TO GET STARTED THEY HAVE PILOT
PROJECT IDEAS WE'D LOVE TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THEM. I AGREE
WITH YOU A 100% SHARE THAT.
JUST TRANSITION STRATEGIES AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT STRATEGIES
MUST HAPPEN FROM THE REGIONS
AND THEIR DIFFERENT ACROSS
REGIONS. AS WE'RE THINKING
ABOUT ARE JUST TRANSITION
ROADMAP IT REALLY IS JUST A SET
OF KEY PRIORITIES. THAT WOULD
ALLOW THE STATE TO SUPPORT
REGION'S TO COME UP WITH THESE
TYPES OF STRATEGIES AND WE SEE
THIS. ONE ARE PROPOSAL AS DOING
JUST THAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND
WEBER THE FINANCE NOTATIONAL
COMES IN THIS ONE ABOUT THE L.
A. L. D. ON THIS THIS ITEM IS
PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE PACKAGE IN OUR
ANALYSIS OF THE OVERALL PACKAGE
WE OFFER TO GENERAL COMMENTS
THAT. RELATE TO THIS ITEM IN
PARTICULAR THE FOCUS ON
WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND
MITIGATION IS MERIT AND THE
MYRIAD. RISKS OF WELFARE
WEREN'T MULTIPLE STRATEGIES AS
THE MINISTRATIONS NOTED
DEVELOPING THE PRIVATE MARKET
FOR FOREST BIOMASS WOOD
PRODUCTS WOULD. COULD ACHIEVE
SEVERAL COMPLEMENTARY POLICY
GOALS AND- THE CALL HAS MERIT
AND IT'S A CONSISTENT WITH THE
GOALS AND- OUTLINED IN THE- THE
GOVERNOR'S WILDFIRE FORCE
MANAGEMENT ACTION PLAN ON TO
ENHANCE SUSTAINABLE TIMBER
HARVEST SO. THE FUNDING REQUEST
BY OPR WOULD FUND FIVE PILOT
PROJECTS AND A WOOD PRODUCTS
EXPRESS. AND WHILE WE DON'T
HAVE WE DON'T HAVE MUCH DETAIL
ABOUT HOW EXACTLY THESE NEW
PROGRAMS ARE BEING IMPLEMENTED-
AND AS THEY WOULD BE COMPLETELY
NEW PROGRAMS WE CAN'T REALLY
ASSESS THEIR AFFECT POTENTIAL
EFFECTIVENESS TOWARDS
DEVELOPING THE MARKET FOR
FORCED. BIOMASS WOOD PRODUCTS.
HOPE YOUR STATUS. FOR REQUEST
CAREER FOR IS TO BEGIN TO
ESTABLISH THE WITH FEEDSTOCK
PILOT PROJECTS IN THE CURRENT
YEAR. AND IN OUR VIEW THIS IS
NOT A COMPELLING RATIONALE FOR
EARLY ACTION FUNDING WELL IT IS
REASONABLE TO ASSUME THAT OPR
COULD PREPARE GRANT AGREEMENT
FOR THESE PROJECTS SEVERAL
MONTHS EARLIER. PROVIDING A
CURRENT YEAR AUGMENTATION THAT
WOULD REDUCE THE LEGISLATURE'S
ABILITY TO CONSIDER THE
SPENDING IN THE CONTEXT OF ITS
BROADER GENERAL FUND
PRIORITIES. SHOULD YOU PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM WE
WOULD RECOMMEND ALSO THAT YOU
ADD ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES SO
THAT WE CAN UNDERSTAND LATER
EVALUATE HOW SUCCESSFUL THESE
NEW PROGRAMS WERE IN DEVELOPING
THE MARKET FOR FOREST BIOMASS
WOOD PRODUCTS. I THINK I THINK
YOU FOR THAT LAST COMMENT
BECAUSE I THINK THE-
ACCOUNTABILITY AND HOW WE-
EVALUATE THE SUCCESS OF THE OF
THE PILOT PROJECT IS GOING TO
BE REALLY IMPORTANT SO IS IT.
TO CREATE JOBS IS IT TOO-
ELIMINATE WOULD WASTE. TIME AND
MAYBE IT'S ALL OF THE ABOVE BUT
HAVING ECONOMY MEASURES I THINK
WOULD BE VERY VERY APPROPRIATE.
CENTER NIELSEN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. I'M VERY. EXCITED ABOUT
THIS PARTICULAR AREA. AND I
MIGHT NOTE THAT THEIR SENATOR
DOLLY AND ASSEMBLYWOMAN DAHLE
A. R. AS WELL. A TECHNICIAN-
DOLLY AND I WORKED TOGETHER AND
I HAVE LITERALLY FOR DECADES.
IN THE MID EIGHTIES I WAS ABLE
TO HELP DON'T DEVELOP A CO
GENERATION FACILITY THAT HAS
BURNED UP 290% OF THE RIFLES.
IN CALIFORNIA WHICH HAVE HELPED
SHAPE THE RICE INDUSTRY AND
ADDITION THAT PARTICULAR PLANT
WAS THE FIRST IN THE WORLD THAT
COULD BURN RICE STRAW. NOW THAT
THAT ISN'T NECESSARILY MY POINT
HERE BUT- THE DECADES BIOMASS
IS GONNA JUST DIED ON THE VINE
IF YOU WILL THAT WOULD ACTUALLY
OVER RESISTANCE TO CITING
BIOMASS PLANTS. AND FOR MANY
REASONS BOTH OF THEM HAVE GONE.
AND AS I JUST NOTED HERE THE
HOLES WOULD BE CONSIDERED AN
AGRICULTURAL WASTE BUT THERE
ARE MANY OTHERS TO LIKE
CHRONIXX ORCHARDS AND VINEYARDS.
AND WE'VE GOT A HUGE PROBLEM IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THE DISPOSAL OF
THOSE WASTE PRODUCTS. AND I'D
LIKE TO PUT OUR STAFF IN TOUCH
WITH THE PARTICULAR AREA UP IN
THE BUTTE COUNTY CALL CAPTAIN
BILL. NOW IT'S GETTING TO THE
POINT. I'M VERY INTERESTED IN
GETTING INFORMATION AS TO WHAT
THE STATE IS GOING TO DIRECTLY
DUE TO ENCOURAGE MORE BIOMASS
DISPOSAL. IN CALIFORNIA FOR OUR
PORSCHE AND OUR WILD LANDS. AND
EVEN AS WAS THE CASE WITH THE-
THE RICE ALL OF THE BY PRODUCTS
OF THE GRICULTURAL WASTE
AGRICULTURAL WASTE- CHAU. IT I
WOULD IT'S BEEN MY IMPRESSION
THAT IN RECENT YEARS THERE'S
BEEN MORE. ATTENTION SPENT TO
THE SHERIFF BUT I THINK I'M
FAIR TO. OUR DRY SENATOR DOLLY
AND MY EXPERIENCE SO IT'S
PRETTY FRUSTRATED. THAT WE HAVE
NOT MADE MUCH PROGRESS SO WE
WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE GETTING
INTO THIS MUCH DEEPER IN A
FUTURE HEARING. MUCH MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW WE ARE
PROGRESSING POLITICAL
GENERATION. DECADES AGO. IN
REGARD MANY DECADES THERE USED
TO BE SOMETHING CALLED STANDARD
OFFER FOR CONTRACTS WHICH WAS A
BIT OF AN INCENTIVE. TWO THE
ONES WHO WOULD DELIVER THE
BOTTLENECKS. I DON'T THINK
THAT'S BEEN AROUND FOR DECADES
AND I'M NOT SUGGESTING THAT
THAT WOULD BE A PART OF THE
FUTURE AT ALL. HOWEVER I AM
INTERESTED IN FINDING OUT WHAT
THINGS ARE BEING DONE TO HELP
FOR EXAMPLE THE CITING. OF BY
AMASH ASSISTING ARE THERE ARE
EVEN- THE MOBILE. UNITS THAT
CAN BE USED TO UNDERSTAND SO IF
WE CAN DO MADAM CHAIR AND A
FUTURE HERE AND GET A LITTLE
MORE IN DEPTH IN THIS AREA I'M
SURE THE DOLLARS AND I WOULD
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR NELSON AND I WILL
TELL YOU OUT OF SECOND WEEK
WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT THAT.
THEY'RE NOT BEING THE APPETITE
IN THE LEGISLATURE FOR BIOMASS-
THAT CONVERSION OF DEAD OR
DYING TREES PARTICULARLY IN THE
HIGH RISE FIRE YEAH I HAD A
BILL FOR TWO YEARS AND COULDN'T
GET IT OUT OF THE ASSEMBLY-
BACK OVER TO THE SENATE AND SO
I'M VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
THIS NOT ONLY HELPS TO SOLVE
AGRICULTURAL WASTE ISSUES. BUT
BOBBY'S HUNDRED FORTY FOUR
MILLION DEAD OR DYING TREES-
MANY THAT ARE CREATING THESE
ARE CRAZY WILDFIRES THAT WE'VE
SEEN OVER THE PAST NUMBER OF
YEARS AND SO- FIVE BOB PILOT
PROJECTS IS EXCITING TO ME AND-
WILL ALSO HELP US TO CREATE
JOBS IN A PART OF THE STATE
WHERE JOBS ARE HARD TO FIND
AND- AND WILL HELP US TO SOLVE
ONE OF THE ECOLOGICAL ISSUES WE
HAVE WHICH IS. THIS THE RAGING
WILDFIRES COULD BETTER FIVE IN
PART BECAUSE WE HAVE SO MANY
TREES THAT ARE NOT NOT ALIVE
ANYMORE AND THAT THAT NEED TO
BE TAKEN OUT SO- THIS IS A- IN
AB- HOLD OPEN ITEM SO WE WILL
WE WILL CONTINUE TO HOLD IT
OPEN AND- AND HAVE SOME ORE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT WHAT THE
MEASURE BOTH MIGHT BE. AND AND
MAYBE THE KINDS OF PROJECTS YOU
ENVISION SUPPORTING THAT WOULD
HELP US TO UNDERSTAND A LITTLE
BIT BETTER- GET THE SIX I.
ABOUT THE- WHERE YOU PROPOSED
ON THIS. SO THAT I ISSUE EIGHT
THANK YOU MUCH- TO THE- FOR TO
BE HERE TODAY FOR THIS
COMMITTEE BUT- WANTED TO SAY.
THIS IS PART OF A LARGER
STRATEGY THAT WE ARE WORKING ON
IN COLLABORATION WITH GO BIZ
AND THAT THERE IS ANOTHER PIECE
OF IT WHICH IS A- FULL TIME
POSITION ECHO BASE THAT WOULD
BE AN INTERFACE TO TRY TO HELP
BUILD OUT THESE MARKETS AS WELL
AS- ALMOST FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS INTO THE CLIMATE
CATALYST FUND FOR MORE IF I'M-
MORE DEVELOPED AND SLIGHTLY
LESS HIGH RISK PROJECTS IN THE
SAME AREA SO. WE SEE IT AS A
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY WERE
ALSO VERY EXCITED ABOUT IT
WOULD LOVE TO TALK ABOUT IT
MORE. OKAY GREAT. THAT SOUNDS
GOOD. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR- YOUR TESTIMONY HERE
TODAY WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING ISSUE
NUMBER NINE ADDRESSING
INCREASED ENFORCEMENT AND
ADMINISTRATIVE WORKLOAD.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON MR WOMAN
AND DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS. HI
MIKE MILLER DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING. ARE
REQUESTED TO ADDRESS THE
DEPARTMENTS HOUSING EQUITY
OUTREACH AND ENFORCEMENT
EFFORTS. DEPARTMENT IS
REQUESTING TWO POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. AND ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND ONGOING. ANY
POSITIONS TO EXPAND THE
DEPARTMENT'S MULTILINGUAL
EDUCATION TRAINING EFFORTS. TO
REDUCE DISCRIMINATION IN
HOUSING EMPLOYMENT. BILL THE
FAIR HOUSING TESTING PROGRAM
INDEPENDENT ENFORCEMENT
CAPABILITY. CITY HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION AND IT COVERED
NINETEEN. AND PROVIDE THE
LEGISLATURE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
AND OTHER AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS WITH VITAL
EXPERTISE ON LANDLORD TENANT
ISSUES. ALL OF WHICH WILL
STRENGTHEN THE STATE'S RESPONSE
TO THE COPRODUCTION PANDEMIC.
YES THE STATE'S COMMITMENT TO
EQUITY AND HELP KEEP
CALIFORNIANS HOUSED AND
EMPLOYED IN THE LONG TERM. THE
LEGISLATURE PREVIOUSLY APPROVED
A THREE MILLION DOLLAR
APPROPRIATION TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. TO FIND
MULTIPLE LIMITED TERM POSITIONS
WHICH HAVE SINCE PURSUED THIS
IMPORTANT WORK. WITH MUCH
SUCCESS IN THE DEPARTMENT. AND
WE WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT IN HELPING TO CARRY
THIS WORK FORWARD. JOINING ME
TODAY IS MERRY WHEAT D. F. U.
H. CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR. AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS DATA CRUZ
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO NOTE THAT THIS
BECAUSE REALLY CONTINUES AND
BUILDS UPON DEFEAT IS VERY
SUCCESSFUL EFFORTS WITH OUR
REGION EDUCATION THAT HAS BEEN
ABLE TO DO WITH A LIMITED TERM
FUNDING AND IN MANY WAYS A
PROVIDE A COST EFFECTIVE
PREVENTIVE MEASURE BECAUSE IF
IT'S ABLE TO. EFFECTIVELY
EDUCATE CALIFORNIA'S AS TO THE
RIGHTS THEY CAN ASSERT THOSE
RIGHTS AND THEREFORE AVOID
COSTLY LITIGATION WHENIT COMES
TO- PROSECUTION OF- UNLAWFUL
DISCRIMINATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- LMAO. GOOD
AFTERNOON MELISSA THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
HAVE NO CONCERNS TO RAISE ON
THIS PROPOSAL. GOOD QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. VETERANS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- HAVING
BEEN A- THE CUSTOMER OF THE
DEPARTMENT TO. FOR MANY MANY
YEARS SEVERAL YEARS AGO. I'M
CURIOUS AS TO THE NATURE OF
YOUR- EDUCATION TRAINING
EFFORTS AND OUTREACH OF BOTH
OBVIOUSLY TO INDIVIDUALS WHO
NEED TO UNDERSTAND THE PROCESS
THE RIGHTS RECEIVE ASSISTANCE
IN FILING APPROPRIATE
COMPLAINTS AND- SECURING
RECOURSE OF. BUT ALSO YOU'RE A
REACH WITH RESPECT TO THE
EMPLOYER COMMUNITY BECAUSE- MY
EXPERIENCE TELLS ME THAT WHILE
THERE ARE SOME BAD ONES AND
PERHAPS MANY BAD ONES DEPENDING
ON WHERE YOU ARE IN A- TIME OF
YEAR. AND THE YEAR. NOT ALL
EMPLOYERS ARE BAD AND MANY TRY
TO DO THE RIGHT THING. SO MAYBE
YOU COULD- MAYBE YOU COULD
ADDRESS THAT FOR ME WAS SOME
SPECIFICITY. I CAN ADDRESS THAT.
HI MY NAME'S MERRY READ I'M THE
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR QUESTION I'D LOVE TO
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'VE DONE IN AND BEEN
SUCCESSFUL AT- SO ONE OF THE
THINGS I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT IS
THAT WE'VE BEEN A KEY PLAYER IN
ASSISTING WITH THE STATE'S
RENTAL PROTECTION EFFORTS- WE
SERVED IN THE BUSINESS
CONSUMER- THESE HOUSING AND
SOCIAL SERVICE TASK FORCE. WE
WERE CALLED READING ACTION AREA
ONE TO ENSURE CALIFORNIA'S
ACHIEVE AND MAINTAIN STABLE
HOUSING FOR RENTAL ASSISTANCE
FORECLOSURE PREVENTION AND
POLICY. SO THIS FUNDING WOULD
CONTINUE OUR EFFORTS AND HELP
US FIND THE POSITION THAT FUNDS
ONE OF OUR CALIFORNIA'S
FOREMOST HOUSING EXPERTS WHICH
WAS THE KEY PERSON THAT HELPED
WITH THE TASK FORCE. I'M TO
SPECIFICALLY ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION REGARDING OUR EMPLOYER
OUTREACH. THIS FUNDING ALLOWED
US TO ENGAGE IN A CONTRACT WITH
SENSYS AGENCY AND WE HAVE JUST
LAUNCHED A KEEP CALIFORNIA FAIR-
MOTION AND YOU CAN LOCATE IT AT
OUR WEBSITE AT U. H. DOT CA DOT
GOV SLASH KEEP CALIFORNIA FAIR
IT HAS VIDEOS AND OUTREACH
MATERIAL THAT TARGET WILL
COMPLY YEARS AND EMPLOYEE USE
THE ONLINE- THAT. WORK THAT D.
F. EACH DOESN'T RIGHTS. OF
CITIZENS IN CALIFORNIA. WE'VE
DEVELOPED A MOBILE APP TO HELP
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES
NAVIGATE THEIR WAY AROUND
UNDERSTANDING THEIR FAMILY AND
PREGNANCY LEAVE BACK. RIGHT AND
WE'VE LAUNCHED A SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PREVENTION TRAINING
ONLINE FREE TO ALL EMPLOYERS
AND EMPLOYEES IN CALIFORNIA- AS
A RESULT OF SB THIRTEEN FORTY
THREE WHICH CAME JUST IN TIME
AS ALL OF THE EMPLOYER
EMPLOYEES A SHELTERED IN PLACE
AND WEREN'T ABLE TO GO TO THE
WORK PLACE TO ATTEND IN PERSON
TRAINING SO THAT WAS JUST
LAUNCHED. WE ALSO REVAMPED ALL
OF OUR PUBLICATIONS AND OUR
OUTREACH MATERIALS AND THEY'RE
AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE WE
HAVE NEW POSTERS AND BROCHURES
AVAILABLE IN MULTIPLE LANGUAGES
AVAILABLE TO BOTH EMPLOYEES AND
EMPLOYERS EDUCATE PEOPLE ON
THEIR RIGHTS AND THAT'S
AVAILABLE VIA OUR WEBSITE AND
THERE IS A SPECIFIC EMPLOYER-
PORTION OF OUR WEBSITE JUST TO
EDUCATE THOSE EMPLOYERS THAT
ARE WANTING TO DO THE RIGHT
THING BUT SHE'S YOU KNOW A
LITTLE HELP NAVIGATING ERROR-
RESPONSIBILITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
HELLO THE CEMEX EFFORT AND I
COMMEND YOU FOR THAT YOU KNOW-
OBVIOUSLY YOU HAVE LARGE
EMPLOYERS SHOULD HAVE THE WHERE
WITH ALL TO. HAVE IN HOUSE
CAPACITY TO PROVIDE ADVICE AND
ASSISTANCE YOU HAVE SOME THAT
ARE SO LARGE BUT HAVE
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES TO HIRE
ATTORNEYS AND CONSULTANTS TO DO
THAT. BUT THEN YOU HAVE A LARGE
GROUP OF SMALL AND EMPLOYERS IN
IN SOME VERY VERY SMALL
EMPLOYERS. WHO DON'T HAVE THOSE
RESOURCES TO EITHER HER LAWYERS
CONSULTANTS FOR STEP UP INSIDE.
AND WITHIN THE LAST YEAR TO
MAYBE MORE SINCE I'VE BEEN UP
HERE WE HAVE. PERHAPS
APPROPRIATELY DRIVEN DOWN THE
THRESHOLD FOR COVERAGE OF MANY
OF OUR LAWS THAT TERM
GOVERNMENT EMPLOYER CONTACTED
EMPLOYEE RIGHTS- BUT WE'VE NOW
DRIVEN LISTS SOME OF THOSE
OBLIGATIONS DOWN TO THE POINT
WHERE YOU'RE DEALING WITH SOME
VERY VERY SMALL. EMPLOYERS
EMPLOYERS THAT IN SOME CASES
HAVE ONE EMPLOYEE IN SOME
CASES. EMPLOYERS HAVE FIVE
EMPLOYEES WHO MAY NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO. COMPUTERS OR THE
INTERNET OR AT LEAST A LOT OF
IT MAY NOT KNOW WHERE TO GO HOW
TO DEAL WITH WHAT THEY SEE ON
THE INTERNET AND I THINK AS WE
MOVE FORWARD AS WE CONSIDER
THIS BUDGET REQUEST IN THOSE IN
THE FUTURE. YOU MAY WANT TO
GIVE MORE THOUGHT TO HOW WE
ACTUALLY DRIVE THIS INFORMATION
DOWN. TO THE EMPLOYER AND
FRESNO OR THE EMPLOYER AND LIFE
THAT HAS MAYBE TWO EMPLOYEES.
IS COVERED BY PROVISIONS OF
FIANNA- AND DEALT WITH BY YOUR
DEPARTMENT BUT DOESN'T REALLY
HAVE THE- THE WHERE WITH ALL.
TO FIND OUT WHAT THE PERSON OR
THE EMPLOYER NEEDS TO DO IT MAY
EXIST AND AGAIN I COMMEND YOU
FOR YOUR EFFORTS I'M JUST
ASKING THAT YOU TAKE ANOTHER
LOOK AT HALLVARD DRIVING THIS
INFORMATION DOWN TO THE- VERY
VERY VERY SMALL EMPLOYER
COMMUNITY SO. AS A STATE AND AS
A STATE DEPARTMENT AND WE TRY
OUR BEST TO HELP KEEP THEM OUT
OF TROUBLE RATHER THAN DEAL
WITH THEM. AS OF ONCE THEY GET
INTO IT THANK YOU VENTURE. VERY
VERY GOOD POINT DEPRECIATE THAT
BOTH COMMENTED AND THANK YOU TO
THE APARTMENT FOR YOUR YOUR
EXPLANATION I WAS VERY HELPFUL.
I'M A LOT OF INFORMATION IS
AVAILABLE HERE FROM. IF PEOPLE
KNOW WHERE TO FIND IT SO I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE ON. THE
MATERIALS THIS IS A HOLDOVER
OPEN ITEM- SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BEING HERETODAY IT
WILL BE SEEING THIS AND ON A
FUTURE DATE WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT.
ISSUE NUMBER TEN WHICH IS PROUD
TO COUNTY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- MY NAME'S ZACH HOLMES
SAID I AM THE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. I WILL- PRESENT AT
HOME HE HAVE NEVER MY
COLLEAGUES HERE FOR SOME OF THE
OTHER ITEMS ON THE AGENDA TODAY
AS WELL- BUT I'LL START HOME
HE- WHIH IS A AND SEVEN OR
FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND REQUEST. TO ALLOW EACH YOU
NEED TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
GRANTS TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
PURCHASE AND CONVERT HOTELS.
AND OTHER FACILITIES INTO
INTERIM IN PERMANENT HOUSING
FOR THOSE PERSONS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. AND THERE IS AN
EARLY ACTION REQUESTED ONE OF
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION- TO
MEET DEMAND INSISTING THE
PROGRAM'S MOMENTUM. THERE'S
ALSO ACCOMPANYING PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO KEEP
THE MAIN COMPONENTS OF THE
PROGRAM WITH A FEW TWEAKS- TO
THE PROGRAM TIMELINES THE
TARGET POPULATIONS AND TO
ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS TO INCREASE
THE PROGRAM'S IMPACT. OF THOSE
INCLUDE EXTENDING THE PROGRAM
TIMELINE. TO THREE YEARS- THANK.
THE TARGET POPULAR TO THOSE AT
RISK OF COMMUNICABLE DISEASES.
AND INCLUDING ELIGIBLE
APPLICANTS TO ALSO INCLUDE
CLEANING AGENCIES LIKE COUNCILS
OF GOVERNMENT- I'LL JUST SAY
ONE THING AND IN REGARDS TO THE
REQUEST. EVERY TIME WE PUT OUT
REQUESTS FOR FUNDING I KNOW
IT'S A FUNDING BILL ABILITY WE
ARE VASTLY OVERSUBSCRIBED FOR
PROGRAMS ANY CD AND HUNKY-
SPECIAL THE FIRST AROUND WAS NO
EXCEPTION. IT WAS TWO TO THREE
TIMES OVERSUBSCRIBED IN EVERY
REGION OF THE STATE WITH THE
INITIAL NO FOR WE PUT OUT. LAST
YEAR OF SIX HUNDRED MILLION AS
YOU KNOW THERE WAS AN INITIAL
TWO HUNDRED MILLION ABA-
AUGMENTATION SO WE ARE ABLE TO
FIND EVEN MORE. BUT EVEN SO WE
ARE VASTLY OVERSUBSCRIBED
DESPITE THE AGGRESSIVE
TIMELINES THAT WE HAD TO NEEDS.
UTILIZING THE FUNDS FROM THE
CURRENT ACTUALLY FUNDS- SO
WE'VE ALREADY HEARD FROM A
NUMBER OF JURISDICTIONS AND
IT'LL FOR PARTNERS. ARE
REACHING OUT ASKING- WITH
SPECIFIC PROJECTS IN MIND WHEN
FUNDS MAY BECOME AVAILABLE
AGAIN. THOSE CONTACTS HAVE
INCLUDED BOTH APPLICANTS AND
NON APPLICANTS FROM THAT FIRST
ROUND OF FUNDING. SO WE'RE VERY
CONFIDENT THAT THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT DEMAND TO- UTILIZE
MORE FUNDS IN THE SPACE. SO I'M
SURE YOU HAVE QUESTIONS I'M
HAPPY. TO ANSWER THEM- AT YOUR
CAN BE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. PRETTY TOPS
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THE ADMINISTRATION STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THIS UP PROPOSAL IN A
SECRET AS AN EARLY ACTION ITEM
SO THAT WE CAN TO QUICKLY
FOLLOW UP ON THE GROUNDWORK
LAID BY THE FIRST ROUND OF THE
HOME HE GRACE- ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LEGISLATIVE ANALYSTS
OFFICE. HELLO THIS MORALES WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. I'M I JUST A MOMENT TO
PUT THIS PROPOSAL IN CONTACT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S BROADER
HOMELESSNESS PLAN THIS IS ONE
OF THREE MAJOR PROPOSALS
RELATED TO HOMELESSNESS WHICH
WOULD PROVIDE A TOTAL OF ONE
POINT SEVEN FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS. TO PROVIDE A NUMBER OF
PROGRAMS AND MAINTAIN BASES
WITHIN EACH CITY BUT ALSO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND PERMANENT SOCIAL
SERVICES ALL THE PROPOSALS TO
FOCUSED ON THE ACQUISITION AND
REHABILITATION OF PROPERTY AS A
RESULT WE DO HAVE SOME SORT OF
BROAD QUESTIONS RELATED TO
MUSCLES FOR EXAMPLE. OF WHAT
OPPORTUNITY IS THERE. FOR A
LOCAL ENTITIES TO MAINTAIN
THESE. PLEASE PROPERTY ONGOING
BASIS NOT ONLY THE MINUTES OF
THE PROPERTY BUT THEN ALSO ANY
NECESSARY WRAPAROUND SERVICES
THAT MAY BE NECESSARY. AS WELL
AS BECAUSE OF THE FOCUS ON
ACQUISITION HELLO ALL THREE
PROPOSALS WOULD WORKS. TOGETHER
TO EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS. RELATED TO THE
HOME HE PROPOSAL SPECIFICALLY.
WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE EIGHT
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS THAT
WAS PROVIDED FOR HOME KEY.
PREVIOUSLY IT WAS UNDER REALLY
TIGHT TIMELINES GIVEN IT WAS
PRIMARILY FUNDED THROUGH
FEDERAL RELIEF THAT HAD THIS
TYPE TIMELINE. THAT WOULDN'T BE
THE CASE UNDER THIS PROPOSAL
WHICH PROVIDES GENERAL FUND AND
SO THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO THINK ABOUT
WHAT OTHER CRITERIAS RATHER
THAN- EXPEDIENCY MIGHT BE MOST
BENEFICIAL AS YOU AWARD THIS
FUNDING TO GOING FORWARD. AS A
RESULT. GIVEN THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT HAS ALREADY GONE OUT
THERE'S OPPORTUNITY TO ASSESS
AND HOW THINGS ARE GOING AND
WHETHER THERE'S ANY NECESSARY.
CHANGES ONE OF THE ISSUES WITH
THE PROJECT ROOM KEY ON WHICH
IS OUR PRESIDENT OF THIS.
PROGRAM ARE SOME CHALLENGES.
WHAT OCCUPANCY RATE. AND SO ON-
SENDING- WHERE THE SUCCESS AND
WEBER THE CHALLENGES AND ONE.
NEED TO BE. ON WOULD BE
INFORMATIVE MOVING FROM. AND
THEN FINALLY AS A RESULT- IN
REFERENCE TO THE EARLY ACTION.
THE KEY QUESTION THERE IS
WHETHER THERE IS IN FACT- CUT
CAPACITY TO- TO MOVE FORWARD IN
THE- CURRENT YEAR. I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY OF YOUR QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. VERY GOOD. COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS YOUR- ROTH IRA.
THANK YOU MANAGER PRESIDENT
JOHNSON. YOU KNOW FOLLOWING ON
THE ALEJO'S COMMENT- GIVEN THE
SHIFT IN THE NATURE OF THE
FUNDING FROM PRIMARILY FEDERAL
TO GENERAL FUND- SHOULD WE NOT
NOW PROVIDE MORE OF A FOCUS ON
ONE ONGOING OPERATIONAL FUNDING
IN THE V- THE NATURE OF THAT
THAN THE EXTENT OF THAT AS PART
OF THIS PROGRAM AND IF NOT.
WHAT WHAT WHAT REALLY IS THE
VALUE OF SIMPLY PROVIDING A
ROOM ISN'T THERE MORE TO THIS
PROGRAM AND TO THE TO THE
SOLUTION OVERALL THAN SIMPLY A
ROOM. BUT AREN'T SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES FOR EARLY CRITICAL ON
HOW DO WE EVALUATE. THAT IN THE
PROCESS WE WOULD CALL THAT A
COMPOUND QUESTION IN LAW SCHOOL
I CAN BREAK IT DOWN BUT THE
POINT IS. ARE WE CONSIDERING
ONGOING FUNDING. SHOULD WE BE
PROVIDING THAT OUT OF THE
GENERAL FUND. AND IF NOT WHY
NOT. I'M HAPPY TO ADDRESS THAT-
SENATORS- PREJUDICE
UNDERSTANDING THERE WAS
OPERATION SUPPORT ARE PROVIDED
TO EACH AND EVERY PROJECT IN
THE INITIAL ON KEY ROUTE IN
FACT THE STATE PROVIDED AT
LEAST TWO YEARS OF OPERATING
SUPPORT UP FRONT OFFER EACH AND
EVERY PROJECT- SO THAT WOULD
CONTINUE UNDER THIS THE
FLEXIBILITY GENERAL FUND WILL
CONTINUE TO ALLOW FOR THAT. AND
I WAS BECAUSE FIFTY MILLION WAS
INCLUDED IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
TO AUGMENT THE SIERRA FUNDS TO
ALLOW FOR US TO PROVIDE THAT
pABLE TO BE CONTINUED.
ADDITIONALLY WE REQUIRED
PROJECTS TO IDENTIFY FIVE YEARS
OF OPERATING SUPPORT SO THEY
WERE ABLE TO DO THAT THE LOCAL
SOURCES OF THE RECEIVING
AUTHORIZED THERE'S QUITE A FEW-
RESOURCE RESOURCE AVAILABLE TO
DO SO- OBVIOUS A LOT OF FEDERAL
FUNDS FLOWING AS WELL SO THAT
IS ACTUALLY QUITE UNIQUE. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT DEVELOPING
PERMITS SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
HOUSING FOLKS ARE HOMELESS-
MAYBE IT'S A DIRTY SECRET BUT
I'M HAPPY SHARED HERE IT'S
OFTEN QUITE CHALLENGING TO FIND
ONGOING OPERATING SUPPORT FIVE
YEARS IS ACTUALLY MORE THAN THE
NORM. SO OUR REQUIREMENT FOR
THAT ACTUALLY NEED THESE
PROJECTS QUITE SUSTAINABLE
WE'RE CONFIDENT THAT- THERE'S A
LOT OF RESOURCES OUT THERE
INCLUDING SOME ADMINISTERED BY
A CD AND ONGOING FASHION HELPS.
DEAL WITH ALMOST IS OF COURSE A
MATTER OF POLITICAL WILL SO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WILL HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO. PRIMARILY FOCUS
THEIR EFFORTS IN THAT WAY
CERTAINLY BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH ALL PROJECTS AND
THAT'S WHAT WE DID THE FIRST
TIME AROUND TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE WAS ADEQUATE SUPPORT
MOVING FORWARD. WHAT IS IT WHEN
IT WHAT WE DO TYPICALLY IS IT'S
ESSENTIALLY CAPITALIZED
OPERATING SUPPORT UP FRONT SO
YOU MAY NOT BE USING IT ALL BUT
YOU'RE DRAWING DOWN FROM THAT
OVER TIME SO WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF OUR- PRETTY LANDMARK
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING PROGRAMS FOR
EXAMPLE DO YOU THAT IT
PROVIDES. A CAPITALIZE
OPERATING SUPPORT UP FRONT THAT
CAN BE DRAWN DOWN OVER TIME AND
THAT'S A SIMILAR MODEL THAT IS
KIND OF BEEN UTILIZED HERE-
WITH BOTH LOCAL SOURCES AND
WHAT THE SORT RESOURCES
PROVIDE. SO I WOULD COMPLETELY
AGREE WITH YOU IT IS NOT JUST
ABOUT THE REAL AND THESE
PROJECTS ARE NOT JUST ABOUT
THOSE THE ROOM THE ACQUISITION
IS QUITE UNIQUE BECAUSE YOU'RE
UTILIZING EXISTING FACILITIES
AND MOST. OF THE TIME HOTELS
AND MOTELS AND I AS WELL THIS
IS FOR LESS EXPENSIVE THAN YOU.
BUT CERTAINLY A HUGE. FOR
INTERIM PERMANENT. IN THAT
OPERATING ZERO SUPPORT WE WERE
A TO BUY THE FIRST AROUND IT
WAS. ANTICIPATED SO. YOU INTEND
TO CONTINUE THE FIVE YEAR.
REQUIREMENT ON A GO FORWARD
BASIS. I THINK THAT'S A GOOD
IDEA FOR A SUSTAINABILITY IN
TERMS OF- MAKING SURE THESE
PROJECTS HAVE THE POLITICAL
SUPPORT LOOK LEVEL BUT WE MAY
EVEN BE ABLE TO PROVIDE MORE
ADDITIONAL OFFERING SUPPORT
THEY WERE THE FIRST AROUND WE
WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE UP TO TWO
YEARS OF THAT FIVE YEARS FOR
EVERY PROJECT- THE FIRST TIME
AROUND SO WE MAY BE ABLE TO DO
MORE OF THAT. GIVEN THE GREATER
FLEXIBILITY OF GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS- BUT WE DO BELIEVE IT
IS IMPORTANT FROM THE OUTSET TO
DETERMINE HOW YOU GONNA FONG I
THINK ANOTHER COMPONENT IS MANY
OF THESE PROJECTS ARE BEGIN TO
OPERATE AS INTERIM HOUSING AND
THEN PLAN TO CONVERT TO FULLY
TO PERMANENT HOUSING IN WHICH
CASE AT THOSE THAT THOSE STAGES
THERE OTHER RESOURCE AVAILABLE
TO THEM OFF FOR THE CONVERSION
AS WELL AS OTHER INCOME STREAMS
WILL NOT ROBUST. ARE THEY WILL
BE COLLECTING RENTS OF COURSE
ON THOSE PROPERTIES EVEN THOUGH
THEY ARE PERMITS FOR HOUSING-
THEY WILL STOP SHORTFALL THEY
NEED TO MAKE UP BUT THERE WILL
BE LESS ONCE THEY ARE GETTING
REVENUE. I'M SOMEWHAT FAMILIAR
WITH THIS. IN IN THE CONTEXT OF
VETERANS. SUPPORT OF HOUSING.
IT WAS BOND MONEY WHICH CAN USE
BOND MONEY TO FOR OPERATING
SUPPORT. AND THE- THE
DIFFICULTY AT LEAST THAT
SOMEWHERE FINDING TRYING TO
SECURE THE- SUPPORT OF SERVICES
COMPONENT OF. PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING OR TEMPORARY
SUPPORT OF HOUSING. HAVE SO AS
PART OF THIS EXPENDITURE
AUTHORIZATION. HAVE YOU
ANALYZED THE FINANCIAL
CAPABILITY OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO PROVIDE ONGOING PERMANENT
AND ONGOING SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
FOR THESE PROJECTS ONCE
WHATEVER TIMELINE USE THAT RUNS
OUT. WELL THAT WAS WHY WE HAD
THE FIVE YEAR RISING THAT THEY
HAD TO COMMIT TO SO THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT WAS PART OF THAT
EVALUATION RIGHT IN WORKING
WITH THEM TO DETERMINE THAT
THOSE WERE REAL AND ACTIONABLE
AND SO WE OF COURSE WANTED TO
SEE IF WE WERE ABLE TO SEE THE
LOCALLY ALL THE PROJECTS WITH
CELEBRITY SUPPORTS IT WAS NOT
COMPLETELY ON THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. AND IN FACT
PHILANTHROPIC PARTNERS CAME IN
WITH SOME ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
FOR QUITE HELPFUL- BUT YES THAT
IS PART OF THE EVALUATIVE
COMPONENT IS MAKING SURE THAT
THESE PRODUCTS ARE REAL
CERTAINTY THAT THE PROVISION OF
SERVICES THE SERVICES PLANS
THOSE ARE ALL PART OF THE ACT
OF THAT APPLICATION- IT IS NOT
IT WAS NOT JUST EXPEDIENCY WELL
THAT WAS QUITE IMPORTANT IN THE
FIRST ROUND. BUT WE'RE
EVALUATING ALL THOSE SORTS OF
THINGS AS WELL AND THOSE ARE
CRITERIA- THAT WE HAD THE FIRST
TIME AROUND AND WILL CONTINUE
WORKING FOR WOMEN IN LIGHT OF
THE FACT THAT WE'RE CONTINUING
AND EXPANDING THE PROGRAM. AND
GIVEN THE FINANCIAL SITUATION
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS UP AND
DOWN. THE STATE SEEM TO BE
FINDING. I GUESS OF THEM. IN AT
THIS POINT DUE TO THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC IN THE
UNCERTAINTY. OF BACKUP FUNDING
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OR
OTHERWISE. WHAT'S YOUR
PROJECTION FOR THE SUCCESS OF
CONTINUED SUCCESS OF THIS
PROGRAM THEN. WELL IT'S A THAT
THERE'S STILL A SIGNIFICANT
INTEREST IN THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT LEVEL RIGHT AND THEY
KNOW WHAT IT TAKES TO DO THESE
PROJECTS WE ARE GETTING A LOT
OF ENQUIRIES ABOUT IF WE CAN DO
MORE OF THIS FROM OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PARTNERS. SO TO SOME
DEGREE THAT IS I THINK AN
IMPORTANT DATA POINT FOR
WHETHER THERE'S COMMITMENT I
WOULD ALSO ADD THAT THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF SOURCES COMING WELL
OF COURSE THERE COULD BE MORE
OVER THE PAST COUPLE YEARS
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF RESOURCES
CAN LOOK GOVERNMENTS
PARTICULARLY FOR HOMELESSNESS.
THAT THEY COULDN'T THEY HAD DID
USE IN THE FIRST ROUND TO
PARTNER WITH THE SIGNATURE
COULD YOU STILL USE MOVING
FORWARD WE HAVE ONGOING- WHAT
WE CALL THE PERMIT LOCAL
HOUSING ALLOCATIONS FROM SENATE
BILL TWO A COUPLE YEARS GO
THAT FLOW TO EACH AND EVERY
GOVERNMENT THEY CAN USE FOR
HOMELESSNESS WE HAVE. A WE'RE
FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO GET IN
FUSIONS IN THE CARERS ACT OF
ADDITIONAL ESG AND CBJ ARE
PROGRAM DOLLARS THOSE OF COURSE
CAN BE PARTNERED MANY MANY
JURISDICTIONS USE THOSE MANY
RICHER SECTIONS USED THEIR
SHEEP AND HALF DOLLARS- WHICH
WERE ADMINISTERED TO THE OUR
AGENCY DID HOMES ACCORDING FIND
A COUNSELOR THERE ARE A LOT OF
RESOURCES THERE- THAT WERE
PULLED IN THAT THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE PULLED INTO
ATTEMPTING TO AT THEIR
DISCRETION- AND WE- WE
ANTICIPATE THOSE WILL STILL
REMAIN RIGHT MANY. OF THOSE ARE
ONGOING SOURCE OF THE FUNDS
THAT THEY CAN. THE GREAT
OBVIOUSLY YOU THOUGHT THROUGH
THIS IT'S A SOUP PROGRAM. AND-
THANK YOU THE PRISON. OF THE
RESPONSE THANK YOU MANAGER.
TURN THE OVEN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. THIS IS AN AREA AND I
MADE A NOTE OVER THIS SECTION.
IN MY PAPERS HERE AREA REQUIRES
INTENSE SCRUTINY. THIS IS NOT A
NEW ISSUE IT'S BEEN AROUND A
VERY VERY LONG TIME. AND THE
STATE AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT RESPONSE TO IT I
WOULD LIKE TO. SOME ASPECTS OF
MODERN ART. WHEREIN THE ARTIST.
SHE DIPS A BRUSH INTO A PACK
CAN OR GRABS A HANDFUL OF PAINT
AND THROWS IT UP ON THE WALL.
AS WE HAVE. RESPONDING TO
HOMELESSNESS BY JUST THROWING
MONEY. AT IT AND THAT'S WHY
YOU'VE GOTTEN SO MANY QUESTIONS
HERE TODAY UP FROM THOSE THESE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. ABOUT
HOW DO WE SEE IF THIS IS
WORKING OR NOT THE RESPONSE OF
THE MOST RECENT- COMMENTER WAS
REAL AND ACTIONABLE. SO THAT'S
WHAT WE REALLY HAVE GOT TO HAVE
PEGGED IN. NOW CANNELLA HOSTED
A AND THE OF THE OUT OF THE
HOME KEY IS KIND OF A
CORNERSTONE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
APPROACH TO DEALING WITH
HOMELESSNESS SOLD THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY REALLY IMPORTANT. AT
AND THE L. L. COMMENTS AS TO
WHAT EARLY STATE ACTION PROVIDE
SUBSTANTIAL ADDITIONAL BENEFITS
NOW THIS IS TO THE POINT DO WE
KEEP POURING MONEY INTO THIS OR
DO WE JUST STAND BACK AND SAY
WAIT A MINUTE WHERE ARE WE NOW.
CHAU WHO WOULD BE DOING THIS
INVENTORY OF THE SUBSTANTIAL
BENEFITS WE WOULD DIRECT WHO
WOULD BE DOING THE INVENTORY OF
THE NEEDS IF YOU WILL FOR STATE
ACTION AND I DON'T KNOW WHICH
DEPARTMENT SHOULD GIVE US THAT
THE THOUGHT BUT MAYBE YEAH.
HOWEVER WOULD PICK UP ON I AM
SUPPORTIVE DEPARTMENT ITSELF
WOULD BE THE BEST. POSITIONED
THAT HOW DO WE IDENTIFY. THIS
AND COORDINATED MUCH BETTER
THAN WE HAVE DONE IN THE PAST.
I'M HAPPY TO WRITE A RESPONSE
ALTHOUGH I DON'T REPRESENT
EVERY ENTITY THAT THAT DATA IS
INVOLVED CERTAINLY IN OUR HOMES
IS CONTINUING I DO UNDERSTAND
THAT- I'M IN A WEEK THERE IS A
HEARING THAT WILL BE FOCUSING
ON HOME BECAUSE OF RACIAL
HEARING OF THE SUB COMMITTEES
AND OTHER COMMITTEES IN THE
SENATE- TO TALK ABOUT THE-
ISSUE OF HOMELESSNESS SO THAT
MAY BEA GOOD A GOOD FORM TO DO
THAT. I A- IT FOR HOME KEY
RIGHT WE ARE JUST GETTING THE
PROJECT REPORTS- AND ANALYZING
THEM FROM THE FIRST ROUND AND
WE WILL HAVE A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE BELIEVE. ALLEGEDLY
REALLY IN APRIL SO- WE ARE VERY
CHEN THE OUTCOMES HERE- THE
EXTENT BY WHICH WE WERE ABLE TO
PROVIDE HOUSING FOR SIX
THOUSANDS OF OUR FELLOW YOU
KNOW SIX THOUSAND PLUS OR HER
ARE FELLOW CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WERE
QUITE PLEASED WITH. WE BELIEVE
IT'S A CRISIS THAT REQUIRES
IMMEDIATE RESPONSE AND I
BELIEVE THAT'S. WHY YOU SEE A
REQUEST FOR EARLY ACTION. WELL
LET ME GO A LITTLE BEYOND THAT
HERE AND THE- ARE ARE
SUBCOMMITTEE AND ANALYSES HERE.
IT MENTIONS AND THIS IS
SOMETHING I'VE HEARD IN THE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AS WELL. LOW
OCCUPANCY RATES AMONG LOOK AT
LEAST UNITS. AND AS THIS IS A
CORNERSTONE HOW CAN WE JUSTIFY
CONTINUING TO PUSH MONEY OUT
WHEN THERE IS A LOW OCCUPANCY
RATE. AMONG AT LEAST UNITS I
THINK THE PREMIUM IS ON THE
AGENCY IN THE DEPARTMENT TO
REALLY GIVE US SOME SPECIFIC.
VERY SPECIFIC PLANS ABOUT HOW
THE AND THE EFFICACY HOW WILL
THIS RESULT RESULTS IN HIGHER
OCCUPANCY RATES THE MEASURE
RULES THAT WE SPEAK ABOUT A
LOT. IT IS NOT A CONCERN THE TO
ALL OF YOU THE LOW OCCUPANCY
RATES. I'M SORRY SOLANO
SPEAKING RIGHT NOW. OKAY SO
THAT BRITNEY BUT IF YOU'D LIKE
TO GO AHEAD AYE I BELIEVE THOSE
COMMENTS ARE DIRECTED FOR- I
KNOW IT'S CONFUSING ROOM KEY
WHICH ARE DARK APARTMENT IS NOT
ADMINISTER BUT THAT WAS THE
LEASING OF HOTELS ARE LEASING
RATES WILL HAVE TO YOU AND
WE'RE FULLY YOU KNOW REFERRAL
FULLY CONFIDENT AHEAD FOLKS
DURING THE MARCH ON ROOM KEY
I'M SORRY HOKEY- WHICH WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE
TODAY THE NOTES IN THAT YOU HAD
IN YOUR- YOUR AGENDA ARE ABOUT
ROOM KEY WHICH WAS A DIFFERENT
PROGRAM NOT ADMINISTERED BY-
THANK YOU FOR. I CAN SPEAK ROKY.
SOMETHING APARTMENT FINANCE. I
JUST WANTED TO KNOW THAT
PROJECT WILL BE SERVED OVER
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
ROUGHLY. FIFTEEN THOUSAND
ROOMS. IN THE OCCUPANCY RATES
FLUCTUATE AS PEOPLE CYCLE
THROUGH THE PROGRAM BUT AT ONE
POINT ALL OF THOSE LINES WERE
INDEED OCCUPIED. AND THEY CAN
SEEM TO BE OCCUPIED ON ALL ON
AN AS NEEDED BASIS. CURRENTLY
TO STATEWIDE OCCUPANCY RATE IS
ABOUT 70% WELL THAT DOESN'T
GIVE ME MUCH COMFORT WHEN I
READ HERE THIS ANALYSES
INDICATING ALL OCCUPANCY RATES
AND DO YOU WORRY AND YOUR AND
YOUR OWN RESPONSE SIR. INDICATE
THAT THERE'S AN EBB AND FLOW.
OF EACH. AND I DON'T THINK
THERE'S A AB AT LEAST IN TERMS
OF THE HOMELESS POPULATION. FOR
THE SHELTER LISH THAT USED TO
BE A TERM FOR HOMELESSNESS. AND
FELLOW. LAST QUESTION HERE THEN.
WHEN DO WE EXPECT AN OVERALL
ACTION PLAN ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT AREA FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION AND OVERALL
ACTIONABLE ACTION PLAN. IT'S
ALSO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
CAN TAKE THAT ONE TWO HCFC IS
PREPARING TO VOTE ON THEIR TWO
YEAR ACTION PLAN NEXT MONTH SO
PERHAPS SOMETIME SHORTLY AFTER
THEY AFTER THEY APPROVE THE
PLAN IT'LL BE ABLE TO BE
RELEASED. THANK YOU FOR. OKAY
AND THAT'S OKAY. WHY I THINK
THE ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED- TODAY ARE THE ISSUES
THAT I HAD CONCERNED ABOUT- I
THINK YOU. FOR PROVIDING ME A
LIST OF THE OF THE- OF THE
PROJECTS THAT WERE APPROVED-
AND THE REASON I ASK FOR THE
PROJECT LIST AS I WANTED TO GET
A GOOD SENSE OF WHETHER THE
RESOURCES THAT WE SPENT THE
CASH MONEY. EIGHT HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS WAS SPENT-
WHERE WE SPENT AND WHETHER IT-
IF THEY WERE AREAS WHERE A
MAJORITY THE MONEY WENT THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS AND SELL OUT MY
APPROVAL OF IT IS I HAD ONE
PROJECT IN MY DISTRICT OF A
MILLION PEOPLE THAT WAS-
SUPPORTED IN IT WITHIN THE CITY
OF SALINAS WHICH IS THE BIGGEST
CITY. IN MY DISTRICT OF A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY HUNDRED
SEVENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE- BUT I
HAVE TWENTY SEVEN CITIES THAT
ARE REPRESENTED EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THOSE CITIES HAVE
ADVISED ME THAT THEY HAVE A
HOMELESS. POPULATION THAT THEY
ARE UNABLE TO SERVE SO TWENTY
SIX OF THE CITY'S DID NOT-
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
AND I THINK THE REASON IS THAT
THE RURAL AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITIES THAT DIDN'T HAVE
THE WHERE WITH ALL TO
IMMEDIATELY RESPOND. TO AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT WOULD BENEFIT
BENEFITTED THE RESIDENTS SO
NUMBER ONE IS I'M CONCERNED
THAT WE DON'T- WE DON'T. USE
SPEED AS THE WAY TO GET MONEY
OUT BECAUSE THEN WE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT- THE
COMMUNITIES AND MAJORITY OF-
LET ME JUST SAY THAT MY- QUICK
PERUSAL. WITHOUT ADDING UP THE
NUMBERS IS THAT A MAJORITY OF
THE FUNDS WENT TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA- LOS ANGELES ORANGE
COUNTY AND SAN DIEGO. AND THAT.
AS I LOOKED THROUGH THE LAST
THERE WERE VERY FEW- RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND SO- IT IF WE'RE
ROLLING OUT A PROJECT TO BE
EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS I
THINK IT MAKE WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION
THAT THERE MAY BE. OTHER NEED
TO MAYBE IT'S A TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WE WERE JUST TALKING
ABOUT OVER IT- PR. BUT THE
OTHER THING IS THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITMENT- AND THAT
WAS RAISED I THINK BY BY BOTH
OF THE SENATORS HERE ON. ON THE
DINER ALL OF US. AND AND WHAT
HAPPENS IF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
CAN CONTINUE. TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES THAT ARE NEEDED IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN
THESE THESE MOTEL ROOMS THAT
ARE NOW- HOME KEY ROOM AND AN
ICE THAT BECAUSE HAVING SERVED
FOR FIFTEEN YEARS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. WHENEVER THERE IS A
DOWNTURN IN THE ECONOMY CITIES
FELT IT WORSE THAN THE STATE IN
THE COUNTY DID- AND AS A
CONSEQUENCE THERE WERE TIMES
WHEN WE CLOSED. ESSENTIAL
SERVICES LIKE RECREATIONAL
PROGRAMS AND LIBRARY SERVICES
IN ORDER TO. FOCUS ON THE MAIN
SERVICES WHICH WE ABSOLUTELY
HAD TO PROVIDE WHICH IS FIRE
AND POLICE AND- THIS WOULD BE
ONE OF THOSE SERVICES. THAT IT
AND QUITE FRANKLY BUT WE GOT
RID OF WAS- EMERGENCY SERVICE
PERSONNEL SO THAT WE HAD NO
PERSONNEL IF WE HAD AN
EARTHQUAKE A FLOOD. OR ANY
OTHER NATURAL DISASTER IN OUR
COMMUNITY BECAUSE WE COULDN'T
AFFORD IT YOU TAKE A RISK AND
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE THINGS
THAT IT'S LIKELY TO GO BY THE
WAYSIDE OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
DOESN'T HAVE THE RESOURCES SO.
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE IF WE
BUILD THESE PROGRAMS- ATM AND
I. I APPRECIATE THE LIST THAT
YOU READ OFF THE HEAT THE HOT-
THE- S. S. B. TO OUR
PROPOSITION TO THOSE ARE ALL
STATE FUNDS. AND AT THE POINT
THAT THE STATE IS IN A CRISIS
AND WE DON'T HAVE THOSE FRIENDS
ANYMORE THEN IT'LL FALL AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO PICK UP THE
SKY SO I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT WHATEVER WE'RE DOING.
NUMBER ONE. ALL COMMUNITIES
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO ACCESS
THE FUNDS. AND CAN DO IT IN A
WAY THAT PROVIDES THEM WITH AN
ALTERNATIVE NUMBER TWO THAT WE
REALLY SET UP A SYSTEM SO THAT-
THE NONPROFIT CAN TAKE OVER
THESE. FACILITIES BECAUSE THEY
HAVE THE EXPERTISE IN RUNNING
THEM. UP AND CAN FUNDRAISEIN A
WAY THAT'S DIFFERENT THAN BEEN
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND- BUT I
THINK IT'S A IT'S A IT'S A
GREAT PROGRAM IT WAS A IT WAS A
BRILLIANT- YOU SEVEN OF KERR'S
MONEY. AND IT IT GAVE US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PUT PEOPLE INTO
INTO ROOMS IMMEDIATELY AND GET
HIM OFF THE STREET I THINK
THAT'S WHAT WE ALL WANT WHICH I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT AS WE
MOVE DOWN THE ROAD. THAT WE
HAVE A PLAN AND IT WORKS HARD
MEETING THIS WITH. THE HE BEEN
HAPPY MONIES IN A WAY THAT THAT
MAKES SENSE AND THAT- THAT
DOESN'T. THE DOESN'T PROVIDE A
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR ONLY SEVEN
CALIFORNIA TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS
RESOURCES THEY NEEDED NO
QUESTION BUT I THINK THE REST
OF THE STATE AS TOO SO THIS IS
A HOLD OPEN ITEMS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION HERE TODAY-
WILL WILL BE TALKING ABOUT THIS
A LITTLE BIT MORE WILL MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN WHICH IS
INFILL INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT.
PROGRAM. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
JENNIFER STEIGER DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR. THE DIVISION OF
STATE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE. AND
I A G. PROGRAM- PROVIDE GAP
FUNDING FOR INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
SUPPORTS HIGHER DENSITY
AFFORDABLE AND MIXED INCOME
HOUSING. IN LOCATIONS
DESIGNATED THEMSELVES. UNDER
THE AYE AYE G. PROGRAM.
DEVELOPERS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN PARTNER TO
APPLY FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING FOR THE PURPOSES OF
WATER IN YOUR OTHER UTILITY.
SERVICE IMPROVEMENT ST ROAD
PARKING STRUCTURE TRANSATLANTIC
CHEN- AND I'D WALK IN THE
STREET. IMPROVEMENTS HCV IS
REQUESTING FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A NEW GENERAL FUND
AUGMENTATION FOR THEMSELVES
STRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAMS THIS
INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION IN CURRENT YEAR
RESOURCES. EARLY ACTION ITEM-
AND ECONOMIC STIMULUS FUNDING
AND AN ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION IN. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO TARGETED
TO ENVIRONMENTAL REPEAT
REMEDIATION OF BROWNFIELD SITES
FOR HOUSING. HCD IS ALSO
REQUESTING TRAILER BILL. THAT
AUTHORIZES GRANTS FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR APPROPRIATION TO BE
OFFERED ON ANY OVER THE COUNTER
BASIS WHAT IS THE DEFINITION OF
QUALIFYING INFILL AREAS AND
PROJECT. ENCOUNTER THE
POPULATION IN UNDER TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND. HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DINNER CRUISE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- WE JUST
LIKE TO NOTE THAT THIS REQUEST
WOULD ADD ANOTHER I THINK YOU
HAVE TO BILLION NEARLY DOUBLING
THE AVAILABLE FUNDS FOR INTO
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH IS
INTERESTING A VERY SIGNIFICANT
SIGNIFICANT BARRIER TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING NAMELY-
HOUSING INFRASTRUCTURE COSTS.
AND WOULDMAKE IT AVAILABLE TO
BOTH A SMALL AND LARGE
JURISDICTIONS. THANK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OHIO. HELLO ONE
SECOND OUT OF MALICE WITH THE
L. A. L. TH AS WITH ALL OF THE
REQUEST FOR EARLY ACTION ON
WHICH IS A COMPONENT HERE WE
JUST ASK ABOUT THE TRANSITIVITY
AND WHETHER THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS MADE THE CASE THAT THERE IS
ENOUGH DEMAND FOR THE CURRENT
YEAR IN ADDITION WOULD LIKE TO
NOTE FOR THE LEGISLATURE. THAT
THERE IS A PROPOSAL FOR THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT TALK TO
SUBSTANCE CONTROL TO
INVESTIGATE AND REMEDIATE
BROWNFIELD SO THERE IS SOME
OVERLAP INTERNET SIMILAR
PURPOSES AND SO ON A DISCUSSION
OF THE ADMINISTRATION ABOUT HOW
THESE PROPOSALS WOULD WORK
TOGETHER ON THIS IMPORTANT AND
THEN FINALLY- AS THE OF THE
DISCUSSIONS COMMITTEES HAD TO
DATE YOU KNOW REFLECTS THERE
ARE ON HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
CHALLENGES AND HOUSING SECURITY
CHALLENGES ACROSS THE STATE
INTO A DISCUSSION OF. HOW THESE
RESOURCES WILL BE TARGETED TO
ADDRESS NEEDS IN ALL
COMMUNITIES IS AN IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION THANK YOU. VERY MUCH
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS CENTER
NIELSEN. YES YOUR BEFORE LAST
IN A HEARING LIKE THIS. I'M
VERY PASSIONATE HOMELESS
ADVOCATES. TESTIFIED FROM THERE
THE TEMPERATURE ABSENT AND HER
COMMENT WAS. THAT WE COULD HAVE
SO MUCH MORE. HOUSING DEVELOPED
WERE IT NOT FOR THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPEDIMENTS AND
COST. AND THE THAT NEEDED TO BE
ATTENDED TO ANOTHER WOULD
REGULATORY IMPOSITIONS ON.
PROVIDING CONSTRUCTING IN
MAKING AVAILABLE. HOUSING FOR
THE HOMELESS POPULATION. HAS
ANYBODY IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. GIVEN ANY THOUGHT TWO
HOW. WE CAN EXPEDITE SOME OF
THESE PROJECTS. EN ROUTE FREE
THEM FROM THE ENVIRONMENTAL
RESTRICTIONS OR PROCESS SEES
THAT ARE IMPEDING THAT. WE
DON'T TALK ABOUT THAT MUCH WE
TALK ABOUT MORE MONEY ALL THE
TIME. BUT MAKING MONEY GO
FURTHER. IS A FUNCTION IN NO
SMALL MEASURE OF GOVERNMENT
ACTION. THE WHOLE THINGS UP. IS
IT. THANK YOU CENTER NELSON FOR
THEIR FOR QUESTION GAINING CRUZ
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'M
CERTAINLY WHEN IT COMES TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING GIVEN THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE ISSUE THERE'S
MANY DIFFERENT AVENUES TO TAKE
TOWARDS- BUT BUILT BOLSTERING
HOUSING PRODUCTION WITH REGARD
TO THIS SPECIFIC PROPOSAL THIS
IS TAKING A STAB IN TERMS OF
ENVIRONMENTAL REMEDIATION BEEN
ON TERMS OF THE REGULAR. I
BELIEVE THE REGULATORY- ISSUES
THAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO BUT
CERTAINLY YOU KNOW THOSE THE
THOUGHTS OF IT YEAH- TAKING ON
ENVIRONMENTAL REGULATIONS IS
SOME THAT'S BEING CONSIDERED
BUT NOT SPECIFIC TO THIS
PROPOSAL. WELL I SUGGEST IF
YOU'RE GOING TO GET MY SUPPORT
MOVING AHEAD DID BETTER BECOME-A PART OF IT. BECAUSE IT IS A
PART OF. AND THIS IS NOT
ACCORDING TO ME BUT I HOMELESS
ADVOCATE. OF PART OF LEADING TO
LIMITING THE AVAILABILITY. OF
HOUSING OR SHELTER FOR THE
HOMELESS POPULATION SO I SUBMIT
SOMEBODY IN GOVERNMENT IN
AGENCIES MAYBE OUR SINGULAR
BETTER GET ON THIS RIGHT AWAY
I'M GOING TO KEEP ASKING THIS
QUESTION THE REGULATORY
IMPEDIMENTS AND COST INCURRED
ON THESE KINDS OF PROJECTS THAT
WE'RE SPENDING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ON. THANK VERY MUCH
SENATOR ON THIS INFILL
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM IS
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR- OF MANY
MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND
I'VE I'VE HEARD RECENTLY OF A
NUMBER OF PROJECTS. THAT ARE
SHOVEL READY WITH THE EXCEPTION
OF RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO DO
THE CURBS GUTTERS SIDEWALKS AND
SEWER. CONSTRUCTION THAT'S
NECESSARY IN ORDER TO BE ABLE
TO BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE
CHALLENGES AS WE HAVE SOME
IMPEDIMENTS. BOB IN IN THE IN
THIS PROGRAM THAT. PROHIBIT A
NUMBER OF THESE PROJECTS ARE
MOVING FORWARD WITH THAT- GRANT
ALLOCATION AND SO I JUST WANT
TO- PUT OPINION THAT AND SAY
THAT- I'M TRYING TO GET MORE
INFORMATION AS TO EXACTLY WHAT
WHAT IT IS ABOUT THE PROGRAM
THAT CREATES THE IMPEDIMENT.
BECAUSE WE COULD SEE SOME
PROJECTS START IMMEDIATELY IF
THESE COULD DIP THESE CARPETS
COULD BE USED IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WERE ACT THAT
I REPRESENT AND I'M TALKING
ABOUT THE COMMUNITIES MADERA
YEAH IT'S GOOD TO FRESNO AND
FIREBALL ALL OF WHICH HAVE
PROJECTS IN AND LAND AVAILABLE
FOR. FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION SO- THIS IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT GRANT PROGRAM
I WANT TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT IT
AND- THIS IS BUT IT'S A WHOLE
TO OPEN ITEM AND- ON WHAT WE'LL
SEE THIS BACK AND IN THE
MEANTIME I'LL TRY TO GET THE
INFORMATION SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
A COP CONVERSATION ABOUT-
WHETHER THERE'S. A NEED FOR A
CARVE OUT- AND IN- AND- IN
ADDITION. BOB WHETHER WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT BROWNFIELDS
REMEDIATION WHETHER THAT
INCLUDES- THE KINDS OF PROJECTS
THAT HAVE BEEN ABANDONED. AND
BECAUSE THE DOWNTURN IN THE
ECONOMY WHERE SOME
INFRASTRUCTURE WAS PUT IN PLACE
BUT NOT ALL OF IT AND IN ORDER
TO START THAT BACK UP AGAIN- IS
THAT PROJECTS ARE GOING TO NEED
A LITTLE BIT TO HELP SOMEONE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE ARE
RESOURCES IN THIS FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. THAT A
MAJORITY THAT COMMUNITIES CAN
ACCESS IN ONE WAY OR ANOTHER SO
THIS IS A HOLD OF OPEN ITEMS
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY WILL MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE WHICH
IS HOUSING LAW. ASSISTANT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS MEGAN KIRBY I AM THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR HOUSING
POLICY WE'RE BACK CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT- THE
HOUSING LOSSES ARE PROPOSAL BUT
SIMPLY IS A PROPOSAL TO STAFF
UP TO HELP. IMPLEMENT THAT AND
THAT. BUT ENSURE COMPLIANCE
WITH HOUSING LAWS ESPECIALLY
THE MANY- THAT WERE
STRENGTHENED OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS- IT ALLOWS US TO EXPAND
OUR COMPLAINT BASED WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING NOW AND REALLY
BUILD OUT AND SOME PROACTIVE
APPROACHES- TO REACH OUT TO
COMMUNITIES AND SEE HOW WE CAN
HELP. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
INCREASE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ARE NOTHING TO. OPERATIVE- FIRE-
A FIBER TOTAL BLANCA. BEST
THANK YOU. LEGISLATIVE ANALYSTS
OFFICE I AM NEW TO THIS MY LIST
HERE UNDER THIS PROPOSAL DOES
HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO HELP THE
STATE MEET IT HOUSING
PRODUCTION GOALS WE WOULD ADD
THOUGH THAT- CHALLENGES AMONGST
LOCALS AND COMPLYING WITH STATE
HOUSING LAWS HAVE BEEN LONG
STANDING AND SO UNDERSTANDING.
HOW EACH CDP IS CURRENT
PRACTICES ARE SHOULD THE BALL
BE TO MOVE THAT. FORWARD IT IS
IMPORTANT ALSO UNDER FOR THE
LOGISTIC THAT THERE IS A OF
PRIORITIZATION PROPOSAL TO HOW
MUCH RESOURCES TO BE DEDICATED
TOWARDS ASSISTANCE VERSUS
ENFORCEMENT AND SO HAVING TO
THE RIGHT BALANCE WILL BE
REALLY KEY. TO THE SUCCESS.
FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH COMMENTS QUESTIONS
FROM. COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YES
CENTER NIELSEN JUST A QUICK
ONE- IT SAYS HCD CAN REVOKE
GOVERNMENT COMPLIANCE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS DON'T ALIGN WITH
STATE LAW. DO YOU HAVE AN
INVENTORY OF HOW MANY ACTIONS
HAVE BEEN TAKEN TOWARDS HE
STANDARD IS JUST A- BIG AREA
REQUIRES A LOT OF PEOPLE I
ISSUE. THAT TAKE ACTIONS AND IF
YOU DO DO YOU GO THROUGH THE
OFFICE OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
OR DO YOU DO YOUR LITTLE THAT
THE- THE ACTIONS ON YOUR OWN
WITH YOUR OWN ATTORNEYS. GREAT
QUESTION I SO I'D GIVE YOU A
SENSE OF THE SCALE- OVER THE
PAST COUPLE YEARS WE HAVE
RECEIVED UPWARDS OF OVER TWO
HUNDRED COMPLAINTS- OF
POTENTIAL HOUSING LAW
VIOLATIONS- AND- ALMOST ALL OF
THOSE WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
ADDRESS- OVER A HUNDRED CASES
RESOLVED THROUGH TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE YOU KNOW JUST-
HELPING CLARIFY THE LAW. AND
MAKE SURE PEOPLE KNOW- AND THAT
WE'RE HERE TO HELP- AND THAT-
THEY UNDERSTAND- WHAT THEIR
OBLIGATIONS ARE. AND THAT THEY
AMOUNT OF HOUSING ELEMENT
REVOCATION WE'VE DONE HAS BEEN
VERY LIMITED- WE CAN DO THAT
WITHOUT- THE ATTORNEY GENERAL-
BUT- ONLY ONE TIME ON IT SO FAR
HAS IT GOTTEN SAID THAT- THAT
LEVEL. AND ADD IT WE REALLY DO
YOU SEE THIS- TO THE BALANCE
AND THE L. A. MENTIONED- WE SEE
EVERY ACCOUNTABILITY AS-
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AS FAR AS
WE CAN TAKE IT- AND ONLY USING
THOSE- THIS AGING RESOURCES TO-
IN A IN A VERY LIMITED AMOUNT
OF CASES. THANK YOU. THANKS
VERY MUCH I AM I JUST WANT TO
SAY ON THIS PARTICULAR ITEM
THAT- THE ENFORCEMENT PART OF
THE LOOK THE LEGISLATION IT'S
NEW IT'S BEEN- REALLY
SUCCESSFUL AS FAR AS I'M
CONCERNED THERE BEEN TIMES WHEN
I'VE RECEIVED- COMPLAINTS ABOUT
ABOUT- PROJECTS THAT WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE MINISTERIAL AND
THEN WHERE THEY GOT HUNG UP. AT
AT THE CITY AND- YOUR OFFICE IS
VERY HELPFUL IN REMINDING THE
CITY THAT THEY HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO FOLLOW STATE LAW
AND TO PUSH HIM TO DO THE RIGHT
THING AND I THINK THAT'S REALLY
THE TACTIC THAT WE WANT IT-
WANTED TO FOLLOW SO WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THAT THIS IS A
HOLD OPEN ITEM AND SO WE WILL
HOLD IT OPEN AND WE'LL SEE IT
BACK- AND ANOTHER TIME. SHE YOU
BEING HERE TODAY ISSUE NUMBER
THIRTEEN ONE TIME ALLOCATION
FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. GOOD
AFTERNOON AT WENDY'S SAYS- AT
BRANCH CHIEF OF OUR ASSET
MANAGEMENT AND COMPLIANCE
BRANCH. IT SEEMS REQUESTED A
GENERAL FUND AUGMENTATION OF
TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
FISCAL YEAR. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND REPAIRS TO
ADDRESS CRITICAL DEFICIENCIES
AT THE OFFICE OF MIGRANT
SERVICES HOUSING CENTERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND EACH
CITY ADMINISTRATOR AS A BONUS
PROGRAM WHICH OPERATES TWENTY
FOUR MIGRANTS CENTERS WITH
APPROXIMATELY AN EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE UNITS AND
PROVIDES HOUSING RELATED
SERVICES ZERO APPROXIMATELY
ELEVEN THOUSAND MIGRANT
FARMWORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
START THE YEAR. HISTORICALLY
RESOURCES IT FOR REPAIRS
MAINTENANCE HAVE BEEN FROM ONE
TIME FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES- THE
PROGRAM'S OPERATING BUDGET
CONSISTS OF A GENERAL FUND
SUBSIDY AND RENTAL REVENUES BUT
AND THERE'S AS LITTLE MONEY
LEFT OVER TO DO SOME OF THE TO
ADDRESS CRITICAL. REPAIRS OR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE NEEDS. I
HAVE AN ANSWER QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. TANKERS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS. OHIO. YES
JUST NOTE THAT THE PROPOSAL
JUST WOULD NOT FULLY FUND ALL
OF THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE- AS
THE COMMITTEES WILL AWARE OF
WHEN PROPERTIES ARE NOT MEETING
TO DOES PUT THOSE PROPERTIES IN
JEOPARDY IN THE LONG RUN IN TO
MAKE SURE THERE IS A PLAN TO
ADDRESS THOSE ON GOING NEEDS
THAT THE FULL BACK I WAS
INTERESTED IN PART IN THE LONG
TERM THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. COMMITTEE COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. FIVE I HAVE- COMMENT
MORE THAN A QUESTION WELL
ACTUALLY I DO HAVE A QUESTION-
I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY- I'VE HAD
IT OVER THE YEARS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TOUR SOME OF
THESE- MIGRANT- HOUSING CENTERS
AND- I'M WONDERING IF- AT LEAST
A COUPLE OF THEM HAVE WASTE
WATER. TREATMENT FACILITIES
BECAUSE THEY'RE AYE THEY'RE
LOCATED AT AB RATHER ISOLATED
AREA AND- AND THE COMPLAINT I
GOT FROM THE MANAGER OF THE
FACILITY WAS THAT IT WAS VERY
DIFFICULT TO RUN A MIGRANT
CENTER AND THEN RUN A RACE
WATER TREATMENT FACILITY WHICH
THEY HAD NO NO TRAINING OR
SKILL FOR- AND LEARN EVERYTHING
THAT YOU NEED TO KNOW TO COMPLY
WITH STATE LAW AND THAT THE
BETTER SOLUTION RATHER THAN
FIXING IT DEFICIENT SYSTEM IS
TO JOIN THAT NEIGHBOR SYSTEM.
AND HAVE SOMEONE ELSE TAKE OVER
THE RESPONSIBILITY I'M
WONDERING IF THAT WAS INTO IT
THAT WAS- A POSSIBILITY THAT
THE CONTRACTOR THAT WAS HIRED
TO DO THE ASSESSMENT- WITHOUT
AN OPTION IT WAS GIVEN TO THAT
CONTRACTOR COULD MY GUESS IS
THAT. THE CONTRACTOR JUST LOOK
AT WHAT EXISTED IN DIDN'T
DIDN'T LOOK AT EFFICIENCIES OR
DID AND DIDN'T LOOK AT- AT THE
NEED FOR A CHANGE AND I WONDER
IF YOU YOU YOU CAN ADDRESS THAT.
WELL AND YOU ARE CORRECT WE DO
HAVE THREE CENTERS THAT DO YOU
HAVE- A DIRE NEED FOR
REHABILITATION THERE SEWER AND
WASTEWATER SYSTEMS I AM. MANY
OF THESE ARE VERY REMOTELY
pTHAT'S A POSSIBILITY WITH
DEPENDS ON HOW CLOSE THEY ARE
TO CONNECTING TO A SYSTEM AND
WE HAVEN'T HEARD ANYTHING FROM
ANY OF THE CONTRACTORS SEVEN
SHARED THOSE TYPES OF CONCERNS
WITH US- BUT- WE CAN CERTAINLY
EXPECT THOSE OPTIONS. BUT YOU
SEEMS TO ME THAT THEM TO THE
EXTENT. IT IT IS. IT'S RARE
THAT WE HAVE AS MUCH MONEY AS
WE HAVE RIGHT NOW. NUMBER ONE
WE'RE LOOKING FOR A ONE TIME.
PROJECTS NUMBER TWO NUMBER
THREE IS B. CENTERS. ARE VERY
MODEST AND I'M VERY OLD AND-
COULD REALLY USE SOME
REHABILITATION INCLUDING
WEATHERIZATION AND SOLAR PANELS
THE KIND OF THINGS THAT MAKE
THEM MUCH MORE EFFICIENT AND-
RATHER THAN. JUST DO SOME
COSMETIC WORK I THINK WE GOT A
LOOK AT WHAT WOULD IT TAKE TO-
TO FIX SOME OF THE- STRUCTURAL
ISSUES LIKE THE WASTE WATER
TREATMENT AND SEWER. AND IF
IT'S POSSIBLE AND WHAT ARE THE
KINDS OF THINGS THAT THAT
WOULD- WOOD ASSIST IN A CLIMATE
WHERE DURING THE SUMMER IT'S
REALLY HOT AND DURING THE
WINTER I'S PRETTY DARN COLD.
SO THAT MY TWO CENTS WORTH IS
THAT IS THAT WE MIGHT WANT TO
SPEND A LITTLE BIT MORE MONEY
ON THIS- AND LOOK AT WHETHER
THERE'S SOME SOME FIXES WE CAN
MAKE THAT WOULD ACTUALLY HELP
IN THE MANAGEMENT OF THE OF THE
SYSTEM SO. HI THIS IS A
HOLDOVER ITEM AND- WILL BE BACK
IN TAKING A LOOK AT THAT
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY HERE
TODAY. AND THERE WERE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
FOURTEEN WHICH IS HOUSING ON
ACCESS STATE LANDS. THANK YOU
MEGAN KIRBY AGAIN HERE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR HOUSING POLICY
EACH CD- THESE PROPOSALS WOULD
PERMIT THREE MAIN THINGS WITH
THAT THREE MAIN CHANGES TO THE
EXERCISE PROGRAM- A- CLARIFYING
AND PERMITTING OF COMMERCIAL
DEVELOPMENT. AS PART OF THIS
PROJECT- A SHIFT TOWARD
CONSIDERING THE MOST POSSIBLE
AFFORDABLE UNITS- VERSES EIGHT
PERCENTAGE OF AFFORDABLE UNITS.
A MINIMUM PERCENTAGE- AND THEN
ALLOWING PHASE DEVELOPMENTS
WHEN IT- ALIGNS WITH THE
STATE'S SCHOOLS. THIS IS A
HOUSING ON EXISTING PLANT.
THAT'S CORRECT. COMMENT TO
QUESTIONS. THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS ON THIS
ONE THIS IS A HOLD OPEN ITEMS
SO- WE'LL WE'LL SEE THIS AGAIN.
MOVING ON TO OUR LAST ISSUE
TODAY WHICH IS ISSUE NUMBER
FIFTEEN THE LOW LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDIT. HI THIS IS
ANTHONY ZERO I AM- WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TAX CREDIT
ALLOCATION COMMITTEE- T. CAC
ALSO KNOWN AS A D. K. WE- IT
MINISTER OF THE LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDIT PROGRAM FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THIS
INCLUDES BOTH FEDERAL AND STATE
TAX CREDITS. OF THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION THAT'S
REFERENCE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- IS SPECIFIC 24%
PROJECTS- AND JUST BY WAY OF
REMINDER 4% PROJECTS. ARE
PAIRED WITH TAX EXEMPT BONDS-
ALLOCATED FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEBT LIMIT ALLOCATION COMMITTEE
SO THAT'S SAID LACK- SOME BE
USING THESE ACRONYMS- IN AB ONE
OH ONE IN TWENTY NINETEEN. MADE
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION AND STATE
TAX CREDITS AVAILABLE 24%
PROJECTS- NEW CONSTRUCTION AND-
YOU KNOW TO SPUR THE PRODUCTION
OF UNITS HOUSING UNITS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND HISTORICALLY
THE BONDS WERE- YOU KNOW UNDER
SUBSCRIBING THAT'LL DUE TO THE
INFLUX OF THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION A LOT OF PROJECTS ARE-
FILLING FINANCING GAPS AND THEY
ARE. PRODUCING A LOT MORE NEW
CONSTRUCTION UNITS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND YES- BY WAY OF
COMPARISON TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUT
WE HAD SLIGHTLY OVER SEVEN.
MOSTLY UNDER SEVEN THOUSAND
UNITS- NEW CONSTRUCTION ON THE
4% SITE AND THEN IN TWENTY
NINETEEN WE ABOUT SLIGHTLY
UNDER FIVE THOUSAND JUST LAST
YEAR WITH THE INFLUX OF THE
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION- WE WERE
ABLE TO DO ABOUT THIRTEEN
THOUSAND- TOTAL HOUSING UNITS-
NEW CONSTRUCTION ON OUR 4%
SITE. AND FULLY- UTILIZE THE
FULL BUS FEDERAL BOND. CAP UP
VERSUS LAST- TWENTY TWO AB
EIGHT THREE YOU KNOW IN ORDER
TO TOOK TO- KEEP THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION- YOU KNOW THEY
REQUIRED THAT DETECT CANCER
BLACK- A LINE BY WAY OF
ADOPTING REGULATIONS- THAT
FOCUSED ON YOU KNOW PRODUCTION
AND COST CONTAINMENT- THROUGH
MANY MULTIPLE MEETINGS OF
PUBLIC MEETINGS- AND VERY
TRANSPARENT PROCESS THESE
REGULATIONS WERE ADOPTED LATE
IN DECEMBER. OF TWENTY TWENTY.
AND THEY ADDRESSED ALL OF THE
ITEMS AB EIGHTY THREE REQUIRED-
SO WE WANT TO- WE JUST RECEIVED
APPLICATIONS- IN THE FIRST
ROUND AND- JUST LIKE THE TV
MENTIONED EARLIER YOU KNOW WE
HAVE LIKE A TWO TO THREE TIMES.
OVERSUBSCRIBED PROJECTS TO
SUPPLY DEMAND- SO HAPPY ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS IF THERE ARE ANY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. GIMMICKRY
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHICH IS
LIKE TO ECHO THAT THIS IS A
VERY VALUABLE RESOURCE THAT IS
HEAVILY RELIED UPON- BY
DEVELOPERS. AND IS GIVEN THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THESE
INVESTMENTS- YOU KNOW KITTY
TECH HAS BEEN TRYING TO POST A
DETAILS AS TO HOW THESE. AWARDS
ARE BEING MADE- AND IT'S POSTED
ON THEIR WEBSITE AND BUT WOULD
JUST LIKE TO NOTE THAT- IT
INFORMATIONAL BE BASED UPON THE
DATA THAT'S AVAILABLE AND SO
BECAUSE THE TAX CREDITS ARE
ALLOCATED. ON A CALENDAR BASIS-
IT WOULD MEAN THAT THE FIRST
YEAR WAS ALLOCATED A SENTRY IN
CALENDAR YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
SECOND YEARS NOW BEING
ALLOCATED THIS YEAR. WITHIN A
FEW WEEKS OF THE FIRST ROUND
AS- MISTER ZERO MENTIONED AND
THEN THE THIRD YEAR THAT RIVER
CAUSING AND TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
QUESTIONS ABOUT HELLO. NO
COMMENT AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- SENATOR
NELSON DID YOU HAVE A QUESTION.
HE THING NO NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS- I GUESS THE ONLY
QUESTION I HAVE IS AND I WOULD
AND I WANTED TO MAKE SURE I
UNDERSTOOD- WHAT WHAT DONE WHAT
WHAT YOU SAID IN REGARDS TO.
THE CHANGES IN THE REGULATIONS
IS THAT YOU'VE DETERMINED THAT-
THAT THE IMPACT IS POSITIVE AND
THAT THERE ARE THE OUTCOME.
FROM FROM MAKING THE SHIFTED AT
THE CHANGE IN THIS PROGRAM HAS
BEEN BENEFICIAL IN TERMS OF
MOVING MONEY OUT AND HELPING
MORE PROJECTS MORE MORE
CONSTRUCTION. WELL LIKE I SAID
THE TWENTY TWENTY WAS THE FIRST
YEAR THAT WE HAVE TO FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION TO MAKE
AVAILABLE- DURING THAT TAIL END
OF THE YEAR- THERE WAS. THEY
WANTED ALIGNMENT AMONG THE TO
COMMITTEES SELECT AND SHE KEPT.
AND SOME OF THE ITEMS THAT THEY
WANTED REGULATORY CHANGES. OR
SPECIFIC TO LOCATION
DEVELOPMENTS WHICH WHICH WAS
ADDRESSED- YOU KNOW
INCENTIVIZING LARGER PROJECTS
MORE UNITS- AND EFFICIENT USE
OF THE PUBLIC SUBSIDIES SO
STATE TAX CREDITS AND THE
BONDS. SO A LOT OF THOSE ALL OF
THOSE ITEMS WERE TAKEN ACCOUNT
AND I THINK THE EFFICIENT USE
OF THE PUBLIC. SUBSIDY DOLLARS-
WOULD SPREAD AMONG MORE
PROJECTS AND THEREBY. YOU KNOW-
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF UNITS
STATE.VERY GOOD I REALLY A-
THAT- IT IS IN THAT EXPLANATION
BECAUSE I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I'VE BEEN THE MOST
CONCERNED ABOUT IS OUR OUR
HOUSING RESOURCES GO OUT IN SO
MANY DIFFERENT FORMATS THAT IS
VERY DIFFICULT FOR DEVELOPERS
TO BE ABLE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
ACCESS TO GRANTS FOR AND
ACTUALLY BE SUCCESSFUL IN
RECEIVING. THE GRANT FROM THE
STATE AND IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE
FROM OUTSIDE OF THE STATE
LOOKING AND SAYING I WANT I
NEED SOME HELP BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- THE FACT
THAT THERE MAY BE THESE GRANT
POSSIBILITIES IN DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS AND THAT ALL LOOK A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT IS VERY
CONFUSING IT'S ALL. IT'S ALL
THE STATE AS FAR AS THEY'RE
CONCERNED AND SO THE MORE THAT
WE CAN- CREATE EFFICIENCIES
THAT'S BETTER AND I'M REALLY
GLAD TO HEAR YOU SAY THAT SO-
THIS IS A HOLLOW OPEN ITEM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE TODAY- AND THAT THAT
CONCLUDES THE LAST OF OUR- OF.
OUR OUR THE PROPOSED FOR
DISCUSSION ITEMS WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO THE PUBLIC COMMENT
REGARDING THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL FOR ITEM RELATED TO
BOTH PART A AND PART B. OF THE
AGENDA AS A REMINDER TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE. SIXTY
THREE SIXTY FOUR AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SIX FIVE FOUR TWO
EIGHT NINE SEVEN. DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEE CHAIRS
MAKE INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY TODAY I'M GOING TO
ASK THAT EACH MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC. PROVIDING COMMENT KEEP
THE REMARKS SECTION ONE MINUTE.
NOW LET'S BEGIN UP WITH ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. I'M LOOKING AROUND AND
THERE ARE NONE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WHO WISH TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ANY OF THE BILLS.
AND AGAIN NOT EMPTY SO- ACT NOW
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
WITNESSES WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCING SERVICE.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT WE
CAN BEGIN. SURE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT PRESS ONE THEN FERAL
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO WELL
AHEAD AND START WITH THE ONE
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GREAT AFTERNOON IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COALITION
FOR YEARS I'M THINKING ON ISSUE
AND WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
INCREASING INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. HOWEVER WE ARE
DISMAYED THAT YOU'RE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ARE
CONTINUOUSLY OVER LEFT FROM
WHAT WE CAN TELL ME TO THE HOME
HE PROJECTS IDENTIFIED. THIRTY
NUCLEAR PROGRAM WERE
DESCRIPTION YOU KNOW THAT YOU
COMMERCENTRE THE PATHWAY TO
CHRONICLE OF THAT. AND THAT THE
CONTINUED UNDER INVESTMENT IN
YOUTH PROGRAMS GOING WILL NEVER.
GET AHEAD OF THE LARGER
HOMELESSNESS PROBLEM- LEFT
SENATOR WIENER'S. TO HAVE A
HUNTER MILLION WHY TIME THAT A-
AND- GREAT YOU HAVE A GREAT FOR
ANNIKA. HOMELESS YOUTH KERN A
FORMER FOSTER YOU CAN. ABOUT
THE AND WE CAN CURRENT.
ENGINEERS ADVOCATE FOR ONGOING
FUNDING FOR HOMELESSNESS. WITH
A 25% SATISFIED FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE OF THE LEGISLATURE HAS
BEEN A LEADER AND PROTECT. YOUR
TYPING OUR YOUNG PEOPLE AND WE
URGE YOU TO CONTINUE TO QUIT OR
STEP I CAN'T IMAGINE ANYTHING
MORE DRAMATIC THAN CAN HAVING
TO SLEEP EVEN ONE NIGHT ALONE
ON THE STREET. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT CALL TO. SO
YOU KNOW WE HAVE ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE IN THE QUEUE WILL NEXT
MOVE TO LINE ONE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS ANNA JOHNSON WITH
JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YEARS
CALLING TO REQUEST THAT A
MINIMUM OF 10% OF THE STATE'S
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO SPENDING ON HOMELESSNESS.
INCLUDING PROJECT HOME KEY BE
DEDICATED TO ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS AMONG YOUTH. NOW
MORE THAN EVER HOMELESS YOUTH
IN CALIFORNIA REQUIRE ACCESS TO
SAFE AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ARE
UNIQUELY IMPACTED BY COVERT
NINETEEN WITH HIGHER RATES OF
UNEMPLOYMENT THAN OLDER WORKERS
AND WITHOUT THE ECONOMIC AND
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT OF AN
EXTENDED FAMILY. YOU'RE
SATISFIED TO WORK WITH A 5%
HE'S SATISFIED IN THAT. COME
WITH EMERGENCY AID PROGRAMS
STATEWIDE JURISDICTION SPEND
MORE THAN DOUBLE THAT AMOUNT ON
YOUTH HOMELESSNESS. AND WHEN
THERE'S NO SPECIFIEDYOU
SATISFIED USE ARE NOT SERVED TO
OUR LOCAL RESPONSE SYSTEM. LESS
THAN 1% OF PROJECT HOME KEEP
SPENDING WENT TO FUND HOUSING
FOR YOU. WHICH MIRRORS THE
FEDERAL LEVEL WHERE WE HAVE
PRIORITIZATION OF CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS AMONG ADULTS
RESULTING. IN A FEW YEARS BEING
START. I TO COME GIVES NUMBER
TO RE. HOW WE IN THE THIS.
INCLUDING WE REACH YOU AND WE
URGE YOUR INCLUSION OF YOUTH
AND IF YOU'RE SPENDING ON
HOMELESSNESS DURING YOU
SATISFIED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE. MAX
HELLO TIELINE ONE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MARTHA GUERRERO REPRESENTING
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND WE URGE THE
PASSAGE OF PROJECT HOME G.
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING AND WE ARE
ALSO A CO SPONSOR THE BRINGING
CALIFORNIA HOME COALITION WITH
DETAILS OF THE- PROPOSAL IS
LISTED IN AB SEVENTY ONE WE
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER
ADDITIONAL FUNDING AS
RECOMMENDED AND DETAILED IN AB
SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE.
MAXTONE MOTEL LINE A ONE TWENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
SHARON REPORT AND WITH THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING AND I'M ALSO PART OF
THE BRING CALIFORNIA HOME
COALITION I'M ALSO SPEAKING ON
ITEM NUMBER TEN. PROBABLY
SUPPORT HOME KEY THIS PROGRAM
REQUIRES ONGOING OPERATING AND
SERVICES FUNDING TO SUSTAIN
BEYOND TWO TO FIVE YEARS IN
MANY CASES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
IMPACTED BY COVERT NINETEEN
WOULD HAVE TO REALLOCATE OTHER
HOMELESS FUNDING TO MAKE HOME
KEY WORKABLE AS THE CHAIRMAN
SHIN. WE PROPOSE INSTEAD
ONGOING FUNDING EITHER TO
REVENUE SOURCES AND ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTY ONE OR TWO GENERAL
FUND FOR COMPREHENSIVE RESPONSE
TO HOMELESSNESS IN ADDITION TO
CAPITAL DOLLARS WE NEED FUNDING
FOR RENTAL AND OPERATING
ASSISTANCE. SERVICES AND IN
TURN HOUSING. WE NEED GREAT
CLUB BETWEEN OUR AGENCIES
IMPACTED BY HOMELESSNESS AND
BETWEEN THE STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. AND WE NEED STATE
REFORMS LIKE STREAMLINING AND
DISCHARGE PROTOCOL. WE SIMPLY
CANNOT MOVE THE NEEDLE ON
HOMELESSNESS WITHOUT WITHOUT
ONGOING RESOURCES FOR A
COMPREHENSIVE RESPONSE. SCALE
TO MEET THE NEED ALONG WITH
STATE REFORMS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
MAXIMO CAROLINA ONE EIGHT PM
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS MARK STIVERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
AND SPEAKING TO ISSUE FIFTEEN
ON THE LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX
CREDITS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
ADDITIONAL FIVE MILLION STATE
CREDITS FOR CALENDAR YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AS STAFF
CORRECTLY NOTES DURING THESE
CREDIT SOLELY WITH THE 4
FEDERAL CREDIT BUT CREATED A
BOTTLENECK FOR TAX EXEMPT BONDS
AT THE DETRIMENT ALLOCATION
COMMITTEE OF THE STATE COULD
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM AND MAXIMIZE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PRODUCTION
IT ALLOWS HE CARE ACT THE TAX
CREDIT COMMITTEE KALECKI STAY
CREDITS ACROSS BOTH BEFORE
PERCENT AND 9% FEDERAL CREDIT
PROGRAMS AS BEST AS CONDITIONS
THAT DICTATE THE BEGINNING IN A
CALENDAR YEAR. WE ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE TO ADOPT TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO GIVE KEY CACTUS
ABILITY PROVIDED THAT LANGUAGE
TO THE STAFF AND WE LOOK FOR
YOU I'M THE HOPE. FOR YOUR
ADOPTION LATER THIS YEAR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
PLEASE. MAXIM OF THE LINE AT
ONE FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD EVENING- COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS ALEXIS AND I'M A FORMER
YOUTH HERE IN BOTH THE PART OF
THE CAMPUS THAT. AS A YOUTH
OVER EIGHTEEN YEARS IN CARE
I'VE EXPERIENCED MANY OBSTACLES
LET'S LET ME GO OVERWHELMING
AMOUNT OF HARDSHIP. FOR THE
MAJORITY OF THE THINGS THAT
I'VE EXPERIENCED THAT THE YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS I HAD LITTLE TO NO
CONTROL OVER THE SITUATION THAT
LED ME THERE. I SAY THIS
BECAUSE MY HEART RESONATES WITH
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE FACING
THE SAME MISFORTUNE. AS A YOUNG
ADULT I USE MY TIME ADVOCATING
COLLABORATE WITH MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS TO IMPROVE AND ENHANCE
THE LIVES OF CURRENT OFFER YOU.
THAT THEY CAN BE THAT THAT THAT
THEY CAN GET OFF THE STREET.
WITH YOUR SUPPORT WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO REVERSE THE
THEOLOGY. AND I BEGAN POLICY
ADVOCATE THE EARLY TEENAGERS I
HAVE SEEN THINGS THAT HAVE
WORKED AND THINGS THAT HAVEN'T
WORKED SO WELL. I CAN TELL YOU
THAT THE 10% YOU SATISFIED IN
WHAT I HAVE SEEN WORK. YOU NEED
A PERMANENT ONGOING FUNDING TO
FOCUS ON STABILIZING. ALLOWING
US TO FOCUS ON ARE USED TO THIS
STUFF NOT ONLY PROVIDE HOPE FOR
POSITIVE EFFECT THE CHANGE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. AND I
STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TEST. NEXT PLAY. MAXIMO DON'T
DON'T WANT AM PLEASED AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KIRTI
I AM FOR SOCCER OKAY AND M. A
FORMER YOUTH WORKING WITH JOHN
BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOU I
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS A FEW
TIMES ON THE U. WHILE HOMELESS
I EXPERIENCE FINANCIAL
EMOTIONAL MENTAL AND SEXUAL
ABUSE WE DON'T YET HAVE A
PERMANENT INVESTMENT FOR YOU
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT FOR THE
10% SATISFIED FOR YOU. TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS BECAUSE IT
IS THE NECESSARY INVESTMENT THE
STABILITY AND FUTURE OF ARE
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT PLEASE. NEXT ALMOST
NINE ONE FIFTY TWO PLEASE GLAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS KAYLA BAILEY I
AM WITH THE VOICES- AND I MAY
USE ADVOCATE I AM HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE COALITION OF MORE
THAN A HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT. CAN EIGHTEEN
POINT TWO MILLION PREVENTION
AND REDUCTION FOR FOSTER YOUTH
HOMELESS PROPOSAL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
NEXT PLEASE. MAXIM OF THE LINE
ONE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
ROSHAN IS TEN AND I WAS
SUBJECTED TO THE CLUSTER CARE
SYSTEM I'M YOUTH ADVOCATE WITH
JOHN BURNS ADVOCATES FOR USE
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF A
COALITION OF ORGANIZATIONS TO
EXPRESSTRACKING SUPPORTS THE
EIGHTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
PREVENTING AND REDUCING COSTS
TO THE COMMISSION'S PROPOSAL.
OF UTILIZATION PORTRAITURE
STANTON. AND OR- THEY WILL
HOUSING IN PEOPLE WHO
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS ARE
LESS LIKELY TO ENGAGE IN
SCHOOL. TO HAVE ACCESS TO
RENTAL HOUSING TO FIND
EMPLOYMENT TO MAINTAIN
FRIENDSHIPS. THAT ARE MORE
LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE SEXUAL
ABUSE VIOLENCE MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
IT SHOULD BE ABLE TO FOCUS ON
SCHOOL FRIENDS PROGRESSION AND
SIMPLY BEING A KID RATHER THAN
BEING FACED WITH HOMELESSNESS
AND UNSTABLE HOUSING. GIVING
ARE YOU STRUCTURE WHEN THEY
NEED IT THE MOST ONE W. CHANGE
THEIR LIVES FOR THE BETTER. HOW
CAN CONSCIOUSLY ALLOW ARE YOU
OUR CHILDREN TO BE LEFT ALONE
TO FACE THE BURDEN OF
HOMELESSNESS. IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO ACT IN
SCORING THE USE. BUT IT'S NOT
WAITING LONGER TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF HOMELESSNESS THAT
FOSTER YOUTH. IN OUR COUNTRY
ARE FACING THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NO PLEASE. MAXIMO
TIMELINE ONE FIFTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS YOUR RECLINER
WITH THE FEINBERG INSTITUTE- WE
ARE MEMBER OF THE BRING
CALIFORNIA HOME COALITION AND
I'M SPEAKING ON ITEM NUMBER
TEN. AS YOU HEARD FROM LOS
ANGELES COUNTY THE CORPORATION
FOR SUPPORTIVE HOUSING- JOHN
BURTON ADVOCATES AND OTHERS WE
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO INCLUDE
THE PROVISION OF ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VINCE REEBOK IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET TWENTY SORRY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET. ARE THE INSURGENTS WORK
FOCUSES ON PEOPLE LIVING WITH A
MENTAL. HEALTH OR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER. ONE BE WITHOUT A
STATE PLATES TO LIVE EXACERBATE
EXISTING DISORDERS AND IT ALSO
CAUSES SEVERE ANXIETY AND
DEPRESSION AND SUBSTANCE USE IN
PREVIOUSLY HEALTHY INDIVIDUALS
SH. OTHER FOR THEM WE'RE
STRONGLY COMMITTED TO AB
SEVENTY ONE ONGOING EVIDENCED
BASED AND ACCOUNTABLE APPROACH
TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS AMONG
PEOPLE WITH MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS. AND WE
URGE THIS COMMITTEE TO
PRIORITIZE THAT APPROACH AS
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. NEXT
PLEASE. MAXIMO TIELINE ONE
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHRISTINA
CURRENT OCCUPANT WILL COMBINE
ADVOCATE THREE I AM HERE ON
BEHALF OF A COALITION OF MORE
THAN ONE HUNDRED ON
IMMIGRATION. WHAT EIGHTEEN
POINT ZERO MILLION CONVENTION.
OSTERHOLM OF. I WOULD LIKE TO
ADD THAT. ONE IN FIVE THEIR FOR
A FAMILY AND OTHER SUPPORT THAT
MY LAN AND AS A FOSTER NUDE I
HAD OR ON ST. OR ANYTHING OUT
WELL OF THE- WHAT. WELL I HAVE
BEEN HOME HOME- IT WOULD BE
NICE TO HAVE SOME SUPPORT THAT
BOSTON COULD. WHILE TRYING TO
HAVE THEIR STABILITY IN MY LIFE
BUT HOW- AND ALSO THANK YOU FOR
OPPORTUNITY. AND HAVE A NICE
DAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR- NEXT PLEASE. MAXO MOTEL A
ONE FORTY AM PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MAXO MOTEL AND FOR THREE CALL.
HI DAVID CAME ARE BEHALF THE
CITY HELLO AND COME ON I GET
THE BRIDGE WHILE AND ARE IN
OPPOSITION. AT ITS CURRENT
WRITTEN WITH CONCERN THAT'LL BE
PART OF COURSE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MAXIM
TELLING ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
MEAN BOTH COALITION FOR SAN
NEIGHBORHOOD CANNOT BE TO
FUNDING ISSUE TWO HOUSING
DISTANCE IN HIS PRESS- BUDGET
PRESS CONFERENCE ON JANUARY
EIGHTH THE GOVERNOR STATED LET
ME JUST MAKE THIS CLEAR TO ALL
MY FRIENDS THIS IS TO MONITOR
CITY COUNCIL MEETING THIS IS TO
MONITOR BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
MEETING PLANNING COMMISSION
MEETINGS. IN A RECENT PANEL IN
THE BAY AREA- THAT HOUSING
FORMER HCD DIRECTOR BEN METCALF
SAID THAT THE H. CD SHOULD BE
MORE LIKE THE CIA. I URGE THE-
BUT- THANK TO USE THESE FOUR
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS TO
ACTUALLY BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE MAXIMO
TO LINE ONE TWENTY TWO. HELLO
THIS IS JORDAN FOLKS- THE
LEGISLATIVE AND POLICY MANAGER
FOR CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION
I'M CALLING TO SUPPORT FOR THE
EIGHTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS PREVENTING AND REDUCING
FOSTER YOUTH HOMELESSNESS
PROPOSAL ATIKAMEKW FOSTER YOUTH
IN AN INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS
EXPERIENCE HOUSE LOOKED AT THE
END ORANGE COUNTY AND LOS
ANGELES COUNTY IT WAS DIFFICULT
FOR ME TO ACTED SERVICES BUT I
WAS ELIGIBLE UNDER EXTENDED
FOSTER CARE. AND I CAN IMAGINE
THE TRIALS AND TRIBULATIONS
INDIVIDUALS ARE EXPERIENCING TO
ACTIVE HOUSING RESOURCES DURING
COLD WITH NINETEEN- BOND WITH
THEM FOR TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
TWENTY THE CAR- CONSOLIDATION
APPROPRIATIONS ACT OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BECAME LAW GOOD
TEAMS- PROVISIONS OF SUPPORTING
POSH YOUTH AND FAMILIES THROUGH
THE PANDEMIC ACT OF THE
ORGANIZATION WE RECOMMEND THAT
THIS FEDERAL SUPPORT IS
IMPLEMENTED BY ISSUING DIRECT
CASH PAYMENTS TO FOSTER YOU.
COLLABORATE WITH ORGANIZATIONS
THAT WORK DIRECTLY WITH YOU AND
TO SUPPORT THE FACT THAT
CALIFORNIA FOSTER CARE- PERSON
IS A POOR VERIFICATION FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ELIGIBLE.
FOR THE FEDERAL FUNDS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
IN MAXIMO COLLIDE ONE THIRD
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY MY NAME IS
A LONG CORRECTLY AND I'M WITH
JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION OF MORE THAN A
HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS SUPPORTED
BY EIGHTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL TO PREVENT AND
REDUCE FOSTER YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS. NEARLY ONE IN
FIVE NEW EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS WHILE IN FOSTER
CARE BETWEEN EIGHT NINETEEN
TWENTY ONE AND ONE IN FORT
HOMELESSNESS AFTER THE EXIT
CARE BETWEEN AGE TWENTY ONE AND
TWENTY THREE DURING THE CALL
THE NINETEEN CRISIS MAINTAINING
HOUSING FACILITY IT
INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT FOR THE
POPULATION THAT THEY'RE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
JOB LOCK IN HOUSING
INSTABILITY. THE PROPOSAL WOULD
ESTABLISH TRAINING FOR CHILD
WELFARE WORKERS INFORMATION ON
HOUSING IN THE HOPE THAT YOUR
SPONSOR THANK I WOULD PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR HELPING
SERVICES LIKE TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING WHICH CURRENTLY HAS A
WAITING LIST OF OVER FIVE
HUNDRED NEW STATEWIDE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR. TIME AND FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT TO OUR YOUNG PEOPLE.
THANK VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE.
MAXIM OF TEN LINE ONE FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD PATRICIA
CRAIN I'D SHARE A NEIGHBORHOOD
ASSOCIATION IN SANTA MONICA
THIS COMMENT CONCERNS ISSUE
TWELVE OUR BOARD STRONGLY
OPPOSES THE FORMATION AND
FUNDING OF THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY UNIT THE STATE
SHOULD RESPECT THE COMMITMENT
AND ABILITY OF LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND PROFESSIONAL
PLANNING STAFF WHO ARE ALREADY
PRESSED BY DEVELOPER LOBBYIST.
WE NEED THE STATE TO SUPPORT US
FINANCIALLY DO WE WANT MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING YES TO
GENERATE MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CITIES NEED FUNDING NOT
POLICING THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE. THANK
SOME OF THE LINE A ONE FIFTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
I'M LOSE MONTEREY WITH
CALIFORNIAN BE OUR FIRST WANTED
IT THANK YOU FOR THAT TOPPLE
CONVERSATION OF IN YOUR FOCUS
ON THE ISSUE HOUSING TODAY AND-
COMMITTEE. MY COMMENTS ARE
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO ISSUE
TWELVE WHICH CALIFORNIA YIMBY
IS VERY PROUD TO SUPPORT- ISSUE
TWELVE BUILDS OFF THE
SUCCESSFUL SIMILAR PROGRAM IN
THE NONPROFIT WORLD. BOOK THAT
BOTH EDUCATES LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ABOUT THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES
UNDER STATE LAW AND ENFORCES
THOSE RESPONSIBILITIES IN
RIGHT. WHEN CITIES WILL
PROBABLY CHOOSE THAT PATH OF
NON COMPLIANCE WITH THE STATE-
AS YOU CAN TODAY IT'S QUITE
IMPORTANT THAT THE STATE BE
AGGRESSIVE IN ENFORCING ITS OWN
LAWS BECAUSE THERE THERE ARE
THOSE WHO WOULD HAVE THE STATE
NOT. I DO THAT YEAH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS NOT FOLLOW THOSE
LAWS. I'M HERE IN THIS PACKAGE
IS THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE-
THAT THE GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING
TO PROVIDE TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
IN MAKING SURE THAT THEY HAN UP
ALL THOSE LAWS WELL. THIS
PROPOSAL CARRIES FORWARD THE
WILL OF THE LEGISLATURE
IMPACTING SEVERAL IMPORTANT KEY
OUT AND WALK AND I STRONGLY
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR TODAY.
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
PLEASE. SOME OF THEM I DON'T
WANT FIFTY- PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON KRISTIN HOW IT
HIGHLIGHTS CHILDREN'S RIGHTS
SPEAKING ON ISSUE CAN WE
SUPPORT INCREASING
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THOSE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
HOWEVER WE ARE EXTREMELY
CONCERNED AT YOUTH EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ARE CONTINUOUSLY
OVERLOOKED. WE KNOW YOU
HOMELESSNESS THE PATHWAY TO
CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS AND THE
CONTINUED UNDER INVESTMENT IN
OUR YOUTH PROGRAMS MEAN
RELIEVING THAT PIPELINE WIDE
OPEN WHERE ARE YOU. WE SUPPORT
SENATOR WIENER'S PROPOSAL TO
HAVE A HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME
FUND DEDICATED TO CREATING
UNITS SPECIFICALLY FOR
UNACCOMPANIED HOMELESS YOUTH.
BECAUSE THAT THAT MAY BE
PREGNANT OR PARENTING CURRENT
OR FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND
JUSTICE INVOLVED USE. CONTINUE
TO ADVOCATE FOR ONGOING FUNDING
FOR HOMELESSNESS WITH A 25%
SATISFIED PER YEAR. YOU FOR OUR
SUPPORT YOUR SUPPORT FOR KIDS
SAFELY ARE YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT PLEASE. MAXIMO TO
LINE ONE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS ANNA
GARRISON TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
PROGRAM DIRECTOR WITH EACH
FAMILY SERVICES- I AM CALLING
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
EIGHTEEN POINT TWO BILLION
PREVENTING AND REDUCING PROCTOR
YOU COMMONSENSE PROPOSAL BUT
THE HAS REALLY MADE GREAT
STRIDES IN THAT THE THING WITH
HOUSING INSTABILITY FOR
COMPLICATED BUT THEY'RE STILL
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS THAT THE
CARRYING BATES AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. I'M WHICH I BELIEVE
THAT THE PROPOSAL WILL HELP
ADDRESS SO THAT YOU AREN'T
FORCED TO EITHER CHOOSE
HOMELESSNESS OR MOVING OUT OF
AREAS- WITH HIGHER RENT BUT
THEY CAN'T AFFORD- TRUE THAT
THE HELP OF THE HOUSING
COMPLEMENT. IT WILL GREATLY
INCREASE THEIR ABILITY TO
REMAIN CLOSE TO THEIR SUPPORT
NEXT NETWORKS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. SOME OF THE
LINE AT ONE FORTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CHRISTINA MILLER I AM
SPEAKING ON ITEM TEN I'M WITH
THE NATIONAL ALLIANCE TO END
HOMELESSNESS WE ARE A MEMBER OF
THE BRING CALIFORNIA HOME
COLLECTION WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO INCLUDING ONGOING
FUNDING SOURCE FROM LOOK AT
PROGRAMS IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET.
PROJECT HOME HE HAVE BEEN A
TRANSFORMATIONAL PROGRAMS THAT
CAPITALIZE ON A LAYER MULLIN
HISTORY WELL WE HAVE A SURPLUS
OF ENERGY HOTELS AND MOTELS DUE
TO THE PANDEMIC TO TURN INTO
HOMELESS HOUSING. NOW ALSO RISE
TO THE CHALLENGE OF THE MOMENT
AND TRANSFORM THE STATE'S
RESPONSE TO HOMELESSNESS I
CREATING AN ONGOING FUNDING
COURSE TO CREATE LASTING
SUSTAINABLE POLLUTION BUT IT'S
FUNDED AT THE NEEDED SCALE
COULD DRAFT A STARK FACT THAT
ONE QUARTER OF THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY PUBLIC POPULATION.
LIVES IN CALIFORNIA. NUMBER
HAVE BEEN PUT APPROACH HAS
PROVEN BE MORE. THAN A TEACHER
KEEP NO PROGRAM. THE HOBBIT HE
BOLD ACTION NOW AND THE BRING
CALPERS HOME BECAUSE- BUDGET
PLACE. AB SEVENTY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. NEXT
PLEASE. MAXIMO CAROLINA ONE
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS SUSAN KIRSCH I'M
CALLING ABOUT ITEM TWELVE AND
I'M CALLING IN OPPOSITION TO
THAT. ITEM I'M I'M A MEMBER OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES FOR LOCAL
CONTROL IN THE COALITION OF
ELECTED OFFICIALS BUT I WANT TO
SAY THAT ELECTED OFFICIALS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT LEADING THE
NEED FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUT
ADDING MORE STAFF AND MORE
ATTORNEYS TO THE H. T. T.
BUDGET WHEN COMMUNITIES
THEMSELVES ARE STRUGGLING WITH
BUDGET ITEMS RELATED TO
COOPERATE AND OTHER DEMANDS. IT
IS UNCONSCIONABLE THAT THERE
CONTINUES TO BE SUCH A HEAVY
HANDED POLICING OR WAS OF ONE
PREVIOUS CALLER REFERRED TO IT
AS A CIA CRIMES OF SURVEILLANCE
OF WHAT CITIES ARE DOING RATHER
THAN TAKING A COLLABORATIVE AND
EXTENDING A HELPING HELPING
HAND TO LOOK FORWARD. I URGE
YOU TO CONTINUE TO LOOK WITH
WITH- CURIOSITY IN OPPOSITION.
TO THIS PROPOSAL. THANK YOU
VERY. NEXT THANKS CAROLINE ONE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY AND MEMBER THAT
THE MATTER NOT OUT OF AFFAIRS
I'M CALLING ON AND YOU ITEMS-
THE FIRST IS AND I NUMBER
ELEVEN- I'D LIKE TO AND OF
COURSE OF THE TO FUNDING- FOR
THE I. A. G. ON BEHALF OF- AND
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIA- ADDITIONAL FUNDING
AND FLEXIBILITY FOR
REMEDIATION- INCREASE
PRODUCTION AND- STRONGLY
SUPPORTED BY THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS- AND I'D LIKE TO
SPEAK ALSO ON ITEM FIFTEEN ON
BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIA- HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY. BUILD AND ARE R.
FORTY BILLION THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA BUILD IS MORE ONE OF
THE ARMY- ORGANIZATIONS THAT
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOMEOWNERSHIP.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FOLKS IN THE
3280% A. M. Y. AND ONE OF THE
FEW IF NOT THE ONLY FUNDING
SOURCES AVAILABLE TO
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE HABITAT IS
CAL HOME WHICH WOULD. BE
ACTUALLY OVERSUBSCRIBED BY A
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE MILLION AND
JUST LAST YEAR- WE WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK THAT AND WE WOULD LIKE
TO REQUEST THAT A PORTION OF
THE FUNDING BEING- PUT TOWARDS
MY TAX BE SHIFTED OVER TO THE
CAL HOME PROGRAM TO ALLOW FOR
OWNERSHIP DEVELOPERS AFFORDABLE
OWNERSHIP DEVELOPERS LIKE
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CHIU AND
HAVE ADDITIONAL PRE
CONSTRUCTION FUNDING. TO BUILD
UNITS BURK FOR FOLKS IN THE
SAME AND MY- AND INCREASE
OWNERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES. IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOUNG. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANKS OF THEM
ONE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU FOR THE ALL TO
COMMENT I'M ADDRESSING ITEM
TWELVE. MY NAME IS EMILY GABEL
LUDDY AND I RECENTLY PASSED
AWAY FROM LOCAL ELECTED OFFICE
AFTER TEN YEARS AND HAVE A
SPECIALTY AND LAND USE AND
HOUSING. FIVE THREE FOUR.
REGARDING A PROPOSED RESOURCE.
AND I DON'T THINK THE STAFF
ANSWERED BEING. IT IS CRITICAL
TO KNOW MORE CLEARLY THE BASIS
OF CURRENT HGV OVERSIGHT AND
BUT AND ENFORCEMENT ACTION.
IT'S JUST ONE HOUSING ELEMENT
WAS REVOKED WHAT IS THE NEED
FOR ADDITIONAL HELPING.
ENFORCEMENT THE COMPANY
REFERRAL BASIS I DID NOT YOU'RE
IN COLLEGE THAT CURRENTLY. ARE
NOT AVAILABLE TO ADDRESS.
SECONDLY HOW WILL BE THREE
SOURCES. JERRY AND WE DEEP DIVE
INTO THOUSAND OF HEALTH SITE I
DON'T THROUGH THE STATE BY
CITIES AS REQUIRED BY THEIR
HOUSING ELEMENT. FINALLY UNDER
WHAT CIRCUMSTANCES WITH THE
WORK OF THIS COULD BE ELEVATED
TO ENFORCEMENT ACTION IS THERE
A THRESHOLD AT WHAT POINT AND
UNDER WHAT CIRCUMSTANCES. AND
FOR STATE GET REFERRED TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IS QUESTIONS
REALLY NEED TO BE CLARIFIED
BEFORE MOVING AHEAD WITH THIS
REQUESTED ITEMS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE.
SOME OF THE LINE ONE NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS ALEX THE SAKE WHAT THE LOS
ANGELES HOMELESS SERVICES
AUTHORITY SPEAKING ON ITEM
NUMBER TEN I'M CALLING TO ECHO
WHAT YOU'VE HEARD FROM FROM THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE AND OTHER
PARTNERS IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTY ONE. WHICH IS A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
HOMELESSNESS WITH ONGOING
FUNDING FOR THE FULL ARRAY OF
INTERVENTIONS THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THIS CRISIS INCLUDING
OPERATING IN SERVICES TO
ACCOMPANY INTERVENTIONS LIKE
PROJECT HOME KEY AND SURE WE
MAXIMIZE THE IMPACT OF PROJECT
HOME KEY. AB SEVENTY ONE ALSO
INCLUDES THE ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES THAT WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT WE GET RESULTS WE NEED A
SYSTEMIC APPROACH AND AB
SEVENTY ONE WOULD DO JUST THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. NEXT CALL.
MAXIM OF THE LINE ONE SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CALL HOLLY CALLING ON
BEHALF OF CITY OF WEST
SACRAMENTO- SACRAMENTO. YOU CAN
GUARD SADDAM NUMBER TEN- LIKE
TO ECHO THE COMMENTS YOU CAME
BEFORE ME AND OFFER OUR SUPPORT
FOR THE ONGOING FUNDING SOURCE
FOR HOMES OF HOUSING PROGRAMS
HAS LAID OUT AB SEVENTY ONE.
BRING CALIFORNIA HOME ACT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU. NEXT
PLEASE. MAXO MOTEL NINE ONE
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK MY NAME IS TAYLOR
NINETY ON THE POLICY ASSOCIATE
AT THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA OR IN PH AND WE ARE
A MEMBER OF THE BRING
CALIFORNIA HOME COALITION WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE INCLUSION
OF THE EFFORTS OF AB SEVENTY
ONE FOR ONGOING FUNDING FOR
HOMELESSNESS SERVICES THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. X. MAXIMO
CAROLINA ONE FIFTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE ONE. BUT I HAD
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JANE
SCHROEDER I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE FIRST PAGE FOR YOU ONE OF
THE LARGEST PROVIDERS THAT
SERVE THE COULD SIMPLY YOUNG
ADULTS AGING OUT OF FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM WE WITNESSED FIRST HAND
THE DESPERATE NEED FOR MORE
HOUSING RESOURCES AND PROGRAMS
THE COURTS TO ENSURE THAT YOU
AGING OUT OF FOSTER CARE DON'T.
A LOT AND THE PRESSURE ON THESE
YOUNG ADULTS HAS INCREASED
EXPONENTIALLY UNDER COLD BENCH
IN OUR PROGRAM ALONE OVER HALF
OF OUR UNITS HAVE LOST JOBS OR
HAD THEIR WORKING HOURS
HUNTINGTON BEGIN WE DO TO THE
PANDEMIC AND IT'S REALLY
THREATENS THEIR ABILITY TO
TRANSITION INTO STABLE HOUSING.
THE FIRST WAVE ALONG WITH A
COALITION OF OVER A HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HERE TO
STRONGLYSUPPORT EIGHTEEN POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLAR PREVENTING
AND REDUCING FOSTER YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSAL AND WE
ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORT SENATOR
RESULTS WINNERS PROPOSAL FOR ON
ONE HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS
BUDGET BY TO INVEST IN HOUSING
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SERVE
TRANSITION AGE FOSTER YOUTH
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY. MUCH NEXT
PLEASE. MAX KALAW WHY STICKS
PLEASE GO OUT. HELLO MY NAME IS
A LOT IS MIA- YEAH OF ALL THE
COLLEGES TO CALL PROGRAM I'M
HERE AND YOU HAVE TO LOOK OF
MORE THAN A HUNDRED TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THE EACH CLINTON
FELT BY PREVENT REDUCE COSTS
CALM COMPOSED- I'D CALL. WE
CLOSE MY HEART AT A WORK IN A
THAT. FORMER AND CURRENT BOSS
USED AND THE BECAUSE TO THEIR
CHANGE. GOOD TO THE PUMP MAKE-
A LOT OF SERVICE HAVE BEEN
ENDING THEM THEIR CONTENT IN
OUT OF AND IS NO WORK THEM TO
SEE HOW. SO I PARTICULARLY WITH
BILL WILL GET HELP. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT.
MAXIMO TIMELINE SIX FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS ZERO ALAN
HANCOCK. I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE COALITION OF MORE THAN
HUNDRED OR A- TOOK THE FOR THE
EIGHTEEN TWO. PREVENT AND
PROCTOR YOU HOMELESS PROPOSAL I
THINK TO WITHOUT THEM HUMAN
NEED IS CRUCIAL THE STUDENTS OF.
FOR PARKING CALL STUDENT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND. THANK
YOU. THANKS FOR. MAXIMO
TIMELINE WINDS FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR
CAVIAR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THIS IS CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF TWO ITEMS FIRST-
WE SUPPORT ITEM FIFTEEN RELATED
TO THE LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX
CREDITS WE ALSO SUPPORT ITEM
ELEVEN BE ADDITIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS FOR
INTEL INFRASTRUCTURE WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO BUILD OFF THE
PROGRESS MADE WITH THE TWENTY
NINETEEN INFILL INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAM WHICH INCLUDED A RURAL
SATISFIED AND OVER THE COUNTER
PROCESS FOR SMALL AND RURAL
JURISDICTIONS. IN A BROAD
DEFINITION OF INFILL THAT
ENSURED THAT PROJECTS IN
UNINCORPORATED AREAS WHICH
REALLY NEED THAT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT CAN
BENEFIT FROM THE PROGRAM THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
PLEASE. MAXIMO TO LINE ONE
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS A MAJOR SETBACK AND
I'M CALLING FROM REVERE
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA CITIES FOR LOCAL
CONTROL EVERY PERSON I KNOW IT
KNOWLEDGE IS THAT HOMELESSNESS
IS A TRAGIC ISSUE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
ALL PUSH FOR SMART FUNDING THAT
CAN HELP RESOLVE THIS MASSIVE
ISSUE HOWEVER. THROWN AWAY FOUR
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS ON
A SO CALLED AFFORDABILITY UNIT
WHICH IS CLEARLY INTENDED AS A
SURVEILLANCE UNIT TO MAKE SURE
THAT CITY COUNCIL FOLLOW WHAT
THE GOVERNOR AND SCOTT WIENER
WANTS THE MISGUIDED AND
MISLABELED BILLS SUCH AS SB
NINE SP TEN IS AN OUTRAGEOUS
WASTE OF FUNDS THAT ARE ALREADY
IN SHORT SUPPLY. PLEASE RE
ASSESS HOW TO SPEND TAXPAYER
MONEY SMARTLY SO THAT YOU CAN
ACTUALLY INCREASE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING RATHER THAN USING IT TO
PUNISH CITIES FOR NOT BUILDING
ADDITIONAL UNNECESSARY LUXURY
AND MARKET RATE UNITS THAT
BENEFIT DEVELOPERS. SOME OF
THIS INFO WASTE MONEY AND
TWELVE. FROM THE UPCOMING
BUDGET AND PLEASE LISTEN TO
YOUR CONSTITUENTS ARE COUNTING
ON YOU TO PASS INTELLIGENT
LEGISLATION. RATHER THAN TRYING
TO REMOVE LOCAL DEMOCRACY FROM
CITY COUNCIL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE.
MAXIMO TO LINE ONE SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE SEVENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY
BE NEEDED. ABOUT SORRY- MY NAME
IS AN ACCOUNT I'M ON HOW THE
POLICY AS AN ORGANIZER IN THE
BAY AREA AND THE RESIDENTS OF
OAKLAND SHOULD THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO SPEAK TO THE COMMITTEE-
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF ITEM
TWELVE HOUSING HOW TO BUILD THE
UNIT. I WORK HARD AND I DON'T
HAVE THE EVERYTHING CITIES
AROUND THE BAY AREA MANY THAT
ARE WORKING HARD. TO ADDRESS
THE HOUSING NEEDS OF THEIR
RESIDENTS AND ALL CALIFORNIANS.
BUT THEY'RE ALSO TOO MANY WHO
ARE MORE INVESTED. AND
EXCLUSION AND EXCLUSIVITY THAN
THEY ARE. IN A GOOD FAITH
EFFORT TO MEET THE HOUSING
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA. I THINK
IT'S RUN ITS IMPORTANT THAT THE
STATE AND PASSING LAWS TO
ENSURE THAT ALL CITIES OF BEING
PART OF OUR HOUSING SOLUTIONS.
NO I THINK THAT UNLESS MORE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY THAT.
WILL BE A GOOD STEP FORWARD TO
ENSURE THE SAME LAWS IN FORCE.
AND THAT CALIFORNIA IS TRULY
FOR EVERYONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT BIGGER PLEASE. MATT
TIMELINE ONE. EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE
INTIMATE MEMBERS- TO CRIME
SALMON RENZI AND LEAD MEMBER
OF- GRASSROOTS HOUSING ADVOCACY
GROUP THAT SOUGHT FOR EVERYONE
I'M CALLING TO EXPRESS STRONG
SUPPORT ON THE ISSUE TWELVE HE
CREATION OF THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT WITH AN HDD
WELL I DON'T THINK ANYONE WOULD
DISAGREE WITH THE NOTION THAT A
CONTINUOUS FUNDING MECHANISM IS
NEEDED FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
SO TOO IS A STRONG OBERST IS
STRONG OVERSIGHT TO ENSURE OUR
CITIES ARE COMPLYING WITH STATE
LAW CITIES HAVE HAD MORE THAN
FORTY YEARS TO GET THEIR
COLLECTIVE HOUSES IN ORDER
UNINTENDED AND HAVE NOT
CONTINUING TO BLINDLY TRUST
THEM TO ADEQUATELY ADDRESS THE
HOUSING CRISIS WITHOUT
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ENFORCEMENT. UNACCEPTABLE
IMPERATIVE THAT THE STATEMENT
ISSUED TWELVE BOARD THANK YOU
THANK. YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
MAXIMO THE LINE ONCE A TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT. WHEN
AMERICAN AND I HAVE A WITH YEAH.
YOU KNOW HOW. TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING AND PROGRAMS AND A LOT
MORE YOUNG PEOPLE TO BE
AVAILABLE. THE MANAGER QUITE.
THANK YOU MUCH FOR AND NEXT
PLEASE. MAXIMO CAROLINE ONCE
FOUR GO OUT. HI MY NAME IS ALEX
I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE TODAY
FOR THEIR TIME I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER TWELVE.
I CURRENTLY. UNFORTUNATELY
STATE LAW HAS NOT BEEN ENFORCED
AND MAKING SURE THAT CITIES
ACROSS. THE STATE ARE PULLING
THEIR FAIR SHARE FOR HOUSING
AND I BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A
GREAT WAY TO MAKING SURE THAT
WE PROVIDE HOUSING. FOR
EVERYONE WHO NEEDS IT I WHICH
IS WHY I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER TWELVE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT PLEASE. MAXIMO TIMELINE
ONE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO I'M MANY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS TO BECOME A
GREAT FROM THE SPARE NET-
FOSTERING CHEESEBURGER NAY IS A
STATE WIDE AGING OP FROM
TALKING TO OF THE WEEK BACK
FROM. I KNOW WE HAVE FIRST HAND
YOU KNOW THERE ARE STRONG ARE
YOU FREE REGARD HOUSE. I'M NOT
DURING THE I MAKE- RELATED TO
THE KIND BUT- ALSO WRITTEN TO
THE HI HOW TO BE CREEPING CAL.
OUR HERE IN SOME OF THE
EIGHTEENTH TWO MILLION PREVENT
YOU KNOW WE COSTS YOU CALL FOR.
THANK YOU. VERY NEXT. MAXIM OF
NO SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME MATTHEW AND KIND
SANTA MONICA AND SUPPORT OF
ITEM TO- THEY DEFINITELY NEED
TO SET AN TO IMPORT HOUSING LAW
AND ENFORCING LAW THE GOOD AND
YOU KIND OF THE PRICE TO HEAR
PEOPLE CALLING AND SAY THEY
DON'T WANT OBEY THE LAW. SO
LET'S MAKE WE GOT THE FUNDING
WHICH MAKES CITIES OF THE LAW
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT PLEASE. MAX TO LINE ONE
ONE AM PLEASE GO AHEAD. I KNOW
FORTY ONE YOU MAY BE IN. HELLO
YES WE CAN AREA. MY NAME IS
JIMMY TOMORROW AREN'T FROM
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I'M A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND ALSO
WORK WITH JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES
FOR YOU AND I'M A STUDENT AT
SACRAMENTO STATE UNIVERSITY I
WANT TO SUPPORT THE EIGHT TEAM
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
PREVENTING AND REDUCING FOSTER
YOUTH HOMELESSNESS PROPOSAL. I
WHEN I FIRST BOOTED OUT OF THE
FOSTER SYSTEM I HAVE TO BE PUT
ON A WAIT LIST. FOR HOUSING FOR
HOMELESS. AND IT LIKE THE WORST
REACHED EVER AND I HOPE THAT
YOU GUYS CAN SUPPORT SUPPORTED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. NEXT PLEASE.
AND OUR LAST COMMENT WILL BE A
FROM ONE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
VICTORIA PIERCE AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF OPERATIONS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ENTERED LEGAL
ADVOCACY AND EDUCATION FUND
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY
UNIT. AS THE PERSON WHO DOES
THE WORK TO ENFORCE LAWS
STATEWIDE BECAUSE DESPERATELY
NEEDED HIM SHOULDN'T BE RELYING
ON CHARITIES WE SHOULD BE
RELYING ON THE STATE GOVERNMENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THAT- INCLUDES ARE THE PUBLIC
PORTION OF OUR HEARING TODAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO THE
MODERATOR FOR ALL OF YOUR HELP-
HAVING HEARD FROM OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC DO YOU HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS BY THE SENATORS. THING
NINE MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
WE WILL I WELL WE'RE GONNA TAKE
UP ITEM NUMBER ONE NUMBER THREE
AND NUMBER FOUR. ON THE VOTE
ONLY CALENDAR. HELLO. SENATOR
RALPH MOVED NUMBER ONE NUMBER
THREE AND NUMBER FOUR. DO I
HAVE THAT RIGHT SENATOR. VERY
GOOD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CABALLERO HI NIELSEN ROTH. SO
THAT LEAVES ONE ITEM LEFT WHICH
IS ITEM NUMBER TWO DO I HEAR A
MOTION ON THAT. MOVED BY
SENATOR ROB PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. CABALLERO HI NIELSEN ROTH.
THAT MOTION PASSES AS WELL TWO
TO ONE. THAT INCLUDES- FIVE ALL
THE MEMBERS HAVING VOTED- THEY
ARE THE ITEMS ARE ALL OUT AND I
WANT TO THANK THE INDIVIDUAL
THANK ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE OR YOU
CAN VISIT OUR WEBSITE. YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US WE PAID A LOT
OF ATTENTION AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD THANK
YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA FOR TODAY'S HEARING.
THE SENATE BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW. SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER
FOUR IS ADJOURNED.